[inaudible]
chicken [inaudible] listening on this [inaudible] to get your groove going,
man.
You can't be on the run.
They say different pages.
US.
How sparks in the house?
He didn't have his headphones on.
You're literally,
this is the coop Brian.
Yeah,
we are the ones CEO's crup.
Yes.
When a time when crack was go didn't hit pop was not yet platinum.
So that's how the stacks,
to quote my mood,
like [inaudible] isn't like when someone else takes the government.
Yeah.
So why are we saying Cooper?
I was thinking chicken coop.
I don't think chicken coops spelled that way brother.
Now and you're right.
If they're going to get below a c,
double o says house parts.
I agree with them.
You
know they are the ones that after nine 11 had that controversial album with the
two twin towers,
I think that were exploding on,
I remember that.
The CD,
damn,
I don't remember that at all,
but I just retention.
Yeah.
That's the way in that way.
That would reinforce the COO concept as a name as opposed to,
I remember when Biggie did the original blow up,
like the world trade and people are like,
Whoa,
what the fuck did you say?
And that's only when a few people had died.
Right.
Bold move.
Cool.
They're taken over folks.
That's what it is.
It's,
I mean,
I guess that's,
those are the kinds of things you're going to save when you're trying to break
through the den of,
of a saturated market.
Yeah.
Before we get into any controversial subjects,
we must thank our sponsor,
the fleshlight.
We are sponsored by a masturbation tool.
Mr. Sparks,
I don't know if you've ever used one of these things.
I have not used it,
but I'm familiar with the concept you have touched on.
These are all virgins and suffer fingers.
Put your fingers inside of it.
Fascinating product,
man.
It works very well.
That's great.
And dairy effect.
It's good.
It's not,
uh,
like,
you know,
it's not just a blue color samples.
It's gonna.
Necrophilia how about the double clearly Yak at you,
right?
Does anybody really ever turn blue?
Huh?
I don't think they ever hit that stage.
Dot.
Color.
Color me high or they're an alien,
right?
Yeah.
Or there really aren't alien.
Or are you trying to body and then it would be for you think a body in the river
looks like that?
Probably it's like blue,
green Yanni,
bloated,
bloated.
Fleshlight I don't know if we look at a silence of the lambs is our reference
point for his body found in the woods.
She was relatively pinkish.
Her fingertips and feet were or bluish.
But I think,
I don't,
they never closed up on the bar.
How many dudes get inspired by those movies to become serial killers?
Like how many people would just want to be someone special so they go,
that guy got caught,
but I'm gonna,
you know what,
I'm going to go out there and do that.
Well,
a lot of them,
a lot of them are too,
uh,
I guess don't have the,
the ability to see it through cause serial killer.
That's right.
That's a commitment.
And most people do the,
uh,
yeah,
sorry,
I don't know how to shut it.
Right.
So I leave it open it oil or something.
It's like,
dude,
my fleshlight went bad.
It's right.
Um,
but uh,
a lot of guys,
what they'll do is they'll get inspired by that,
do the workplace violence thing,
go up and shoot a girlfriend,
shoot a shoot up their office.
Those,
that's where those guys come from.
And then they ended up shooting themselves cause it's nothing like they expect
it.
Is that why they do,
what are the,
most of the time I'm shooting themselves in the first place.
Some,
some say they do or whatever,
they are going to commit suicide by cop or whatever.
But a lot of them go down because they're looking at the dead people and going,
this is nothing like a movie.
This is nothing like a video game.
This is nothing like I thought.
And then they just can't take it.
Yeah.
They have this because of the guys who've survived trying to kill themselves.
That's,
that's what they said.
Christ how fucking,
it just shows the broad spectrum of human thinking and behavior.
Oh yeah.
No,
people are,
it's so fascinating.
You know,
when you just,
you know,
just you meet someone and you just can't jive with this guy,
this guy's broken or he's fucking wacky or whatever and you're like,
God,
I could have just met the coolest person in the world instead.
I met the Douchey is personal random,
right.
You know,
it's,
if someone,
like in the other world who's running the game controller that runs that
particular body in this environment,
it's as if he handed the controller to his friend and would just try the game
for awhile.
You know what I mean?
A second ago there was a guy who knew how to run.
It was like,
okay,
I'm living a good life.
I've got a guy going,
he's pretty interesting.
And then he hands it to his friend who's never played the game before and he's
like,
fuck,
I keep running into the wall.
You know,
there's a lot of people that just keep running into the walls.
Totally.
Your,
you'll run into people that I've met people in my life that easily could've been
shooters.
They easily could have,
you know,
they're just,
Oh yeah.
One tragedy away.
One ass kicking away,
one life ass kicking,
you know,
you lose your job,
lose your house.
You know,
Lewis was the one in high school.
I wasn't that far off.
Really?
Yeah.
For Real.
What was it about belong,
Huh?
No,
no,
it was a,
it was,
I came from the country like stick built,
you know like Kentucky and I moved to Chicago in the first year I was there.
I was pretty fucking miserable because I was such an outcast and it was so like
it was a super rich school is I went from a school that had 140 people in my
class to 1400 in my class,
like,
and,
and I had a southern accent and fucking peach fuzz mustache and we were broke
and I lived in a guest house up the street and all these kids were like Roland
and Mercedes and that kind of stuff.
And I had that kind of outsider like anger about it.
And then what solved it was,
was the fact that a girl,
two girls approached me at,
uh,
at a party at the same time.
And it occurred to me that they're,
there was,
there was a fork in the road here.
I could go violent Hal or I could get laid and this was the choice and I,
I went with getting late.
Wow.
So your response to just being an outcast,
you just,
you want it to get violent with them?
Yeah.
Well certain ones of them,
I mean I into a bunch of fights the first
like,
like three months I was there,
I almost got kicked out.
Is that about people that,
you know,
new people can come around.
They just immediately sensed the weakness and want to start fucking with that.
There's some people that just do that.
You know?
I had the same situation in my life where I moved around a lot.
We moved from Tom,
I was seven,
we moved to New Jersey or two from New Jersey to San Francisco.
Lived in San Francisco until I was 11 and then 11 to 13 lived in Florida and
then 13 to 24 I lived in Boston.
Right.
So it was the same sort of thing.
It was like you never really get settled,
you know,
and right when you develop some friends and start,
having like a little base of people you hang out with and it seems like life is
normal.
Yeah.
For kids.
That's fucking huge,
man.
If you don't have friends,
you don't have a life,
like tell the adults think that they can just fucking take your kids and snatch
them out of someplace and it's not going to hurt them to just,
while you're just going to get used to Kansas,
you know?
And then they get Douche on in school and they don't have any friends anymore
and meanwhile they had the coolest friends ever back home and wherever the fuck
they're from,
that's a traumatic fucking thing for,
yeah.
I think as an adult you just kind of,
it's,
you do take some level of friendship for granted because you start recognizing
the world as a relatively big place in a positive sense,
and that there are people to hang out with everywhere you go and you overlay
that thought form on a new brain,
it doesn't quite land as well.
The issue is I think that,
well,
you know,
really it's just a hurdle and you got over it and I go over it and most kids do
get over it.
In fact,
it could be argued that the best way to make an interesting person as to put
them through a fucked up child.
Absolutely.
Because pretty much everybody that I know,
that's interesting.
All of my friends had fucked up childhoods.
I don't have any normal friends where,
you know,
they talk about their childhood.
It was just like my dad was always there for me.
He took me to fucking wrestling practice every day and my mom always bake cakes.
None of them,
nobody ever hear any of that shit.
And most of the ones I do meet our relatively miserable.
Yeah.
And I spend a good deal of my time entertaining a lot of them.
And do you think that they're normal to you think they're just different,
different ones?
Sublimate we need directions for life.
Goddammit.
We need a fucking guide.
This is ridiculous that we get stuck into the most complicated puzzle.
Any living organism that we can comprehend can go through the idea of evolving
as a human being,
becoming a productive member of society,
getting your emotions in order,
getting your your energy in order,
getting your life in,
order,
your friendships in order.
That's fucking Uber complicated hand.
And we don't even have a guidebook.
Well,
but the guidebook would be wrong at the crucial point is the problem.
And by the way,
we've tried to set up guidebooks there,
but would there be a way to have a guide book just for clarity of thinking,
just objective clarity of thinking and letting people understand.
I think that's like a giant percentage of what the problem with human beings is,
is that there,
even if they find the answer,
if the answer doesn't jive with their life,
they're,
they're not willing to accept it.
You know,
they get angry about whatever it is.
Everything has to bottleneck through there.
Their,
their past.
People just have these fucking rigid ideas in their head and once,
once those ideas are challenged and then it becomes a battle for their soul,
you know,
it becomes,
it's not just,
uh,
you know,
they disagree about an
issue and I'm not totally attached to it.
I've had great conversations with people that are super,
really super appreciate when they're not attached to their idea.
You know what I mean?
Right.
When they're not like arguing in a real personal way,
when it's like,
you know,
you,
you were like,
when they're in,
not in insecure about,
yeah,
they just have an idea about things.
That's the only way human beings ever evolved.
But the problem is life is a big Dick contest and everyone's wants their idea to
be the best idea.
So they tried to force right.
Than happy.
Yeah,
exactly.
And the people who's always trying to be right are never happy.
No.
Everyone,
incidentally,
the most miserable.
Winning is the only sense they had the most miserable people the most who always
want to be right.
You know,
and anybody in places where it's not right,
like there's a comic that I know that would always criticize people's acts and
tell him like,
what are you doing this for?
Man?
You can do better than this.
And the guy liked his act but does act as like super juvenile [inaudible] like
that kind of shit.
That's really the same thing.
It's like what would you,
what are you saying?
What you like,
right?
You want everyone to like what you like.
Exactly.
Dick.
It's absurd.
It's,
you know,
for an extreme example,
it's one of the things when I laugh at people who go off on Nickelback or
something like that,
or even carrot top where you're like [inaudible] they literally go bunch of
corporate assholes who just sell our shit and you go,
wait a minute,
what Elvis Costello Song should they be doing in a coffee house to make you
happy?
Because
even at balance to help what you like exist to some degree and you need to leave
that shit alone.
If it doesn't resonate with you,
knock,
you know,
cares.
Um,
I,
it's not successful is what it is.
It's too successful and it's too smooth and it's too packaged.
What it is is they're good.
Right.
Good pop band.
But I mean it's like I met that Nickelback guy too.
It was,
they were doing a man.
Yeah,
man recently.
Yeah.
I was at the uh,
UFC and there they had a show the night before the UFC.
Like [inaudible] Alon.
No,
we get our nails done together.
Him Mad.
I was getting my knuckle shave and he was getting his hair done.
You got,
you got,
you got to whack that.
I want to let everybody know I'm Harry everywhere.
I don't give a fuck.
And you're at linens and things and I met the guy from Nickelback.
There's,
that's one of those universal,
easy to hate Justin Bieber type thing.
Like I don't have a problem with Justin Bieber.
I it seem like he's a little kid.
Right.
That's what I mean.
Fucking Justin Bieber,
if all you're one more fucking Justin Bieber song.
I'm like,
what channel are you listening?
You go outside and go for a walk,
smell some flowers for a radio stations.
There actually are.
Fuck,
where the fuck is your iPod at this point?
You know,
it's interesting.
We were talking about five by and load one more Justin Bieber song on my own
iPod and listen to it as I sleep.
I'm going to kick my own and get started.
One More Justin Bieber song.
We're fighting every night.
I'm going to beat myself up.
Do you remember that kid?
Um,
I don't remember his name but he did.
he performed that Paparazzi Song.
Um,
it did it in like a school talent show and he has this incredible voice.
His name is like glazing or something like that.
God Damn it.
Somebody put it up on the board.
Have you heard about that recently?
That's like eight years old.
Somebody throw that up on my Twitter cause you know who it is.
If a kid was on Ellen is a,
okay.
Anyway,
they,
uh,
the kid has this insane voice and the video is this really intense video because
it's like,
it's,
if you haven't seen it [inaudible] oh dude,
you've got to pull it up.
Pull that video up so he can watch this and we could talk about this.
You know what his name is or anything like child prodigy singer.
Uh,
Ellen.
I don't know.
We'll find out what the,
what the fuck is his name?
Twitter verse.
Yeah.
You know,
you know who I'm talking about?
God dammit.
You freaks.
Uh,
I'll check my Twitter feed.
Mills Wells.
It's a girl or guy.
It's a dude or uh,
it was Justin race.
Yes.
That's his name.
Grayson.
I thought it was glazing cause there's a fighter named glaze and t bow.
Those like testing me.
What are you doing?
No,
that's not what you're doing Brian.
Which is go,
there's a video.
There's a video of him in like a town.
Now what does that fucking commercials?
Yeah.
Then I'm,
yes,
that's it.
That's the video.
Grace in Michael,
somebody to here.
He goes,
oh,
now check this kid out.
This is a fucking like seventh grade talent contest.
Okay.
Check out these bitches in the audience you have never seen like pure,
animalistic connection and attraction.
These women can't help their little girls.
I shouldn't say women.
These little girls are fascinated by what this kid can do and the difference
between them and him.
It's like a jazz them between like a rat in a god.
You know?
Look at these girls in the audience there.
Stare at this kid now WIC,
WIC.
Did you hear this motherfucker?
Buses shit out.
Hello?
[inaudible]
I've never done anything that good in my life.
There's a girl in a bad on though.
Listen to this kid's voice.
Got Her hand on her.
Yeah,
she starts playing with her hair.
Yep.
And her hand goes away and she starts looking around the room.
Does everyone else reacting to simply this fucking kid's voice?
Listen to this
[inaudible] I've
never been that good at anything in my life and I never will.
Joe.
Never left moment.
I'll never hit that moment.
Really.
Joe Never,
never listened to this song alone.
Jeff,
listen dude,
listen to this kid's voice.
This motherfucker's nailing this.
He's like,
Oh,
11 oh,
I get it,
and he's in front of a talent contest.
Nobody even knows he's doing this.
This motherfucker's connecting to Gaia right now.
He's a little kid and he's figured out how to do this.
You know why it hasn't gotten any pussy yet?
No one's broken as hard.
No one's taking his money.
He's never had to work for them for food.
He's not getting in his own way is what it exactly.
Listen to this mother fucker.
I think he needs to check his ego though.
Watch
the girl who had her hand on her face was just riveting pitches.
He hypnotized.
She's going to be every guy who fucks her for the rest of her life.
She's going to be thinking about this kid singing in the background.
She's going to try to Facebook him when she's 40 and she has kids and divorced.
Oh really?
She's Never gonna forget this kid ever,
and he and his partner.
We'll be living happily in Michigan.
Could be.
I wonder if this room for just John Meyer,
this motherfucker.
Yeah.
I wonder if this room smells the same at the end of this song as when it
started.
I think it smells the same as a fish store.
No,
I couldn't possibly their children,
those little bitches of breeding man hormones in the beef.
That's not what egg smell.
Listen to every one of those little flux can get pregnant if they were gone.
They were banging.
They'd have kids at all of the kids.
Gorillas in the mist.
Yeah.
We are gorillas in the,
here's the thing too,
this is,
he's got a purity of emotion that he's connecting to,
but it's not the same as what's happening in that song.
Yeah.
What fascinates it's his own,
your raw fears as a kid,
your raw disconnection.
That has nothing to do with the content of them.
Lyrics.
Nothing just fit.
Right.
I mean he's singing about
paparazzis and cigarettes and you know,
that shows you about music man,
that it's,
it really is
all art a window into purity,
a window into like purity of expression and it doesn't matter if you even know
the words to what you're saying.
No.
Well that's the thing.
You don't Melanie,
that's the resonant path.
There's,
it's like a sound freak thing,
but,
but when you hear words that nail it to tell,
it brings in another level when it's like the perfect lyric along with the
perfect music.
Music is such a trip man.
Yeah.
Why band rehearsal last night for three and a half hours.
And they were,
we were working on some stuff and we're adding like songs to the lineup and
stuff that I hadn't with my,
uh,
former band mates had never been able to sort of get the vibe of,
came really naturally with these guys.
And so it was like we're standing there after the song going,
oh,
that was exempt band is called zero one,
right.
The word zero and the number one.
Yeah.
But,
um,
but I've,
I,
you know,
if you leave me alone and,
and there's nothing else to do,
if I don't have a place to go or whatever,
what I do is write music.
Wow.
And it's,
and I can sit with a guitar and start writing stuff.
And so the,
and I and I,
I feel like I'm ready to at a certain point where I've written songs that
actually matter to me.
And once you get to that point,
you,
you get that,
you get,
it's spooky almost because you don't feel,
you feel removed from yourself.
It's like great standup when you do a show and you,
you feel like you're watching yourself from behind.
Like your body is acting out the parts.
You're totally committed to what you're saying.
But part of you is like your ego's not there.
Yeah.
And you're real spirit is like 10 feet and you feel like behind you.
I always say that you feel like you're,
you are a passenger.
Yes.
You know,
you don't really feel like you're driving,
you're a passenger and I guess you have
your hand on the breaks in case shit goes terribly wrong.
Totally.
But you have maintenance stuff to do.
Yeah.
Right,
yes.
Yeah.
But a lot of the times,
you know,
especially when you just in the perfect groove.
Yeah.
And everybody says the same thing too.
You know?
I mean,
it's interesting.
It's a mechanic.
It's a mechanic that happens naturally.
I think it is,
and it's,
it's any kind of art like that.
And I think that's,
and that's,
that's the beauty is what he's singing has nothing to do with what's in the
words of that song or what the intention of the original artist was or any of
it.
It's just that those notes in that order shake some part of him and knock
something honest.
Loose.
Yeah.
There's something like about one song that really nit hate.
Dude put up.
I'm counting crows,
Mr. Jones and me know,
dude,
I love this fucking song.
Why do you oh no one.
That's all right.
And don't like that song.
Hell No.
Listen Dude,
it was 1993 1993 I was living in New York.
Star minds me phones.
It's a good fucking song.
Even if that did,
did Bang Jennifer Aniston.
Yeah.
That's all I can think of though.
I was living in New York and I saw this video.
I was watching MTV and I saw this video.
I was like 1992 or 1993 and I was like,
God,
if I could just get as comfortable as this motherfucker right.
Cause it was just so comfortable,
relaxed into what it was when he was singing and you know,
he was dancing around singing that song.
I was like,
this guy is just in that zone.
What's wrong Mr. Jones?
You don't get the same feeling I had when I listened to black label society.
Stillborn.
Ah,
I'm not kidding.
It's a commercial right now,
but would be one set of commercials.
Yep.
Going back to the child prodigy.
Have you heard of the Mati be wrapped?
He's the seven year old prodigy rapper and he is fucking amazing dude.
He is for seven years old.
I have a song for him too,
if you want to hear it.
So I'm like,
oh my God.
Yeah,
let's throw him on.
Okay,
here's a,
let's do Kesha.
You'll see he'll do,
he's seven years old.
Remix it.
Keys.
Yeah.
Hold on.
There was two things.
Plan.
Yeah,
that happens on occasions.
Can't tabs baby.
Talk to Matty B and Cra counting crows.
Mattia hey.
Oh by the way,
message to all you people out there with fucking music on your websites.
Cut that shit.
What?
What is it?
1998 I go to your website and music starts playing
and a midi file even worse.
Exactly.
And I'm searching all of your stupid website for the little.
Shut it off and sound off.
What the fuck is wrong with you fellow?
Okay.
You don't need,
I had music on my website too.
I apologize.
So long time ago.
We're from that.
What are you doing Brian?
He mixing.
You'll get details.
Yeah.
Tom,
seven years old.
Seven.
What's his name again?
To sit down and watch these guys.
Test and intimidation about Maddie.
Be wrapped on the jeep like this one.
Be Girls on the board about the boys.
Try to be fun,
easy.
And Keith dot doubted that you grow midnight.
Go so next to you while you rapping.
I'm a solo show.
This man on the Macy's parade boat boat off going up seven pounds now due to the
opponents.
She's terrible.
Terrible.
It's awful.
It's,
you got brain damage,
bro.
That's fresh.
No parents manipulating a child.
That is.
That is total.
They basically had this kid in their living room,
like acting out what he saw and they decided to turn it into something.
Know what that kid needs to live his life a little bit more.
You know,
we need to tell that kid come back when you were 11 yeah,
but a bit Mc Chris's sweat.
He's going to be awesome.
Yeah.
Mc Chris is sweating right now.
You know what,
Mc Chris,
that's his real voice is calm.
Yeah.
He's like,
well,
if that's his real voice,
well actually they're both real voices,
but I'm see Christmas as a super high pitch.
Real voice.
That's how he wrapped it.
Sounds.
Ah,
yeah.
I can't live in that zone.
You can't live in guidance that music goes,
it's not good to me.
Doesn't resonate.
Burt's counting crows.
They still fucking 70 no kid,
dude.
Well,
I mean the,
the style,
here's the thing is a lot of times when when they come up with just like there's
this prodigy,
you can do this kind of music.
He's a seven year old who does this,
whatever.
I feel bad for all the people who do that for a living because it basically says
your shit is so easy to do.
I can make a monkey do it.
I can really take a kid who's a six year old could do this bullshit.
How much?
Who's smarter?
Six year old or a champ.
They've done those studies.
Six year old.
Depends on
what kind of chimp.
Yeah.
Okay.
This is,
this is the song I was living in new Rochelle and the shitty ass apartment that
smelled like cat piss cause my cat used to pee by the door.
She was mad at me.
That'll go away for too long.
I come back,
she pissed by my door.
So here I am,
my piss smelling cat house
wondering what the fuck is happening with my career.
What am I doing?
How do I get good?
Yeah.
How do I get good at this comedy thing?
I got these fucking moments where I feel it all comes together and I listened to
this guy singing this and I'm like,
man this guy's not trying to beat.
He's not trying to be anything other than what he is.
Man,
I wish I was beautiful and he's dancing.
I'm like,
tell him stop.
No,
this is a good fucking song,
dude.
And that guy's in the groove,
man.
What he's saying this,
he's having fun.
He's relaxed.
He's not worried,
meaning they know this.
That's my issue with any music.
Long as you mean it.
I don't care.
As long as you're sincere,
dude,
this guys,
he's in the grove,
he's in the groove and I remember saying,
thinking that like,
man,
if I could just get as relaxed as I fucking guys,
that's like 90% of it getting the who the fuck you really are?
You know?
Ready.
Set Action.
Fucking scammers and the what?
Huh?
Lights on you microphone.
Whoa.
Is this even real life?
Right?
You like that little kid coming back from the dentist?
It's all fucked up on drugs.
90% of it is getting to what this guys at right now,
that 10,000 hours,
man.
A lot of a lot of these guys,
especially at this to thinking too,
it's not just the hours.
10,000 hours is the mastery number.
Yeah.
You know,
but it's not just that.
There's 10,000 hours of open makers that suck and they,
they can't get over the hump man.
There's,
it's not just a time,
it's a thing.
No,
I agree.
But in his case,
getting to a level of good,
getting to a skill level and then playing probably at 15 years old,
they were probably musically as good as they are now physically like,
you know,
as far as quality of play.
Yeah.
Are you a big counting crows fan?
You know?
No,
but I mean like the guys guys in uh,
um,
and the black rose were like that.
A lot of these bands started out when they're 15 in high school bands by the
time this shit comes out there,
25 they've been playing for 10 years from high school bands to the legit playing
through college,
always in bands doing it again and again and again fucking up,
getting better,
getting,
you know.
And then at the end of it they're like,
I was as good a player 10 years ago as I am right now.
But now I know what,
why am playing the notes as opposed to how to
play them or where you just know yourself more.
You know,
with time as time goes on,
you just know what notes are,
you know,
where,
what resonates resonates with you.
You know,
and that's the to 90% of what it all is,
is finding out what the fuck you do.
Every band starts off almost diametrically opposed to where they end up in a lot
of cases in a lot of people call it selling out or like look at the police.
Police is a great example.
They beginning basically a punk band and then by the time they hit what was
legit,
who the police are as ours,
everybody likes it.
It's very commercial and yet still acceptable as genuine art.
It's,
you know,
it's almost diametrically opposed to where they started out
sort of.
You know?
I know what you're saying.
We've talked about that with some bands,
but I always attributed to success fucking up their motivation.
I always say times,
but sometimes you,
someone has that pain and they don't have that pain anymore.
You know,
when you have that,
that struggled at the desire to be loved,
the exceptional desire to be loved.
I mean,
that's where most music art,
anything really comes from,
right?
And when you get rich in,
you're just banging all these hot bitches,
you know,
and then he started singing uptown girl,
that's where it comes from,
right?
I mean,
that's what happened.
Billy Joel,
if you go,
this is my perfect example.
Now if you go and listen to old Billy Joel,
even it's a guy singing and the piano.
And that might not be for you.
And I totally get that.
But if,
but just listen to what this guy's doing,
man.
This is like real shit.
I agree.
You know,
like the ballot of Billy the kid,
that's a powerful fucking song.
Captain Jack,
Dude,
Captain Jack will get you high tonight.
That's a great fucking song,
right?
That's,
that's a beautiful song about a dude who's in pain.
You know,
that's about a dude who's trying to figure out life.
That's,
it's a real song.
He called from that uptown girl what happened,
right,
right.
What happened?
I Dunno,
I,
I think you are the master.
You tapped into the fighting chronic.
I yawned,
disconnect from that,
from their pain.
It doesn't mean it doesn't exist anymore.
Different drugs,
you know.
Well,
I,
I just had a burn probably.
Yeah.
I think you're gonna let antidepressants and cocaine.
The cocaine.
Yeah.
Alcohol.
Alcohol is an earthbound drug and thickens your lower bound experience.
And,
and,
and hallucinogenics and,
and cocaine are our resident drugs.
They get you out of your body.
No.
Europe's trade edge.
You're a total straight edge.
Now this has been from me.
And if people don't know what that means,
that's no drinking,
no drugs,
no nothing.
Yeah.
Coffee,
uh,
on rare occasion,
but now it's as strong as it gets.
Yeah.
And what is the rational rationale for this?
It's a lot of reasons.
Um,
the,
it started out as,
you know,
I'm part native and,
and Scottish,
it's not a good idea to get,
go down that road.
Alcohol wise,
my family,
you know,
you'd go that road,
you keep walking it until,
you know,
it's natural.
And I've seen a lot of people,
the family.
Yeah.
And not just my direct family,
but ancestral roots.
And it was,
you know,
I always joke,
it's kind of like the,
I don't drink the same reason.
Like a lot of Jews don't drive German cars.
There's a little bit of like,
it was used as a weapon,
so fuck you.
Um,
the other reason is is I,
I didn't want the plant to become the fertilizer and for me,
I wanted to find out who I was without added elements or added magnifying
glasses from the outside.
I wanted it to be,
it's,
to me,
drugs represented sort of like a,
a trampoline that allows you to see the top of the mountain.
But if you want to get there,
you still have to eventually get off the trampoline and do the work.
Meditatively or,
or focus,
find yourself,
you can see yourself on drugs.
I have no question that there are people,
especially higher order drugs like pot and,
and,
and mushrooms and those kinds of things are more organic drugs that,
uh,
you know,
I think you can see the essence of who you are and even the essence of the
universe through those things.
I don't doubt that for a second,
but you got to come back and it's not your win necessarily.
And I think you,
you in your life,
your,
your existence deserves the respect of walking there yourself,
getting to that space so that you can see it and say,
I own this space as opposed to somebody handed it to me.
That's interesting.
That's a really interesting way of looking at it.
Here's a story.
Um,
uh,
a Buddha,
Buddha ran into this monk.
This monk was a,
I'm walking to the town and then the monks at the Buddha,
I have a practice,
a city of levitation,
and I can now walk on water.
I've worked on this for the last 40 years and the Buddha looks at the monks and
says,
but the ferries Olien nickel,
right?
That's an old Terence Mckenna joke by the way.
I share and it's,
it's an old story that he used to tell that's a true story that did the ideas.
The idea behind it is you can get there way quicker.
I agree.
But in this case,
the ferry has,
has a rubber bands attached to the end of it that bring you back and,
and you can't stay.
Yeah.
But there's an element of thing from it.
I think personal experience without you having the personal experience,
right.
It's,
I have babies and I've done mushrooms and I always tell people,
unless you've done either one,
don't talk about them because it's the,
the,
the experience of mushrooms is so much more alien than you could ever possibly
imagine.
Okay.
And so this,
the idea that you could somehow or another look at it from the outside and say,
well,
I think it allows you to see outside.
I don't know,
but I don't view it.
Yeah.
I don't view it as an ever done it.
I know,
but what I'm saying,
never not
done it now.
Yes,
I have.
I've lived a huge part of my life without doing it,
but not as you now and until you are until I was in my thirties okay.
But that still there is an element of you are now you plus mushrooms for the
rest of your life and for the rest of your experiential life and the rest of
your,
how you see the world.
And I'm not saying that's a plus or a minus in so far as the worth of your life
by any stretch,
but I have made a choice to be me as me with no plus or minus.
Totally see what you're saying.
Respect your choice.
What I'm saying is,
you know,
so talk anybody out of it.
You were also you plus vitamins.
You are also using protein,
you plus water.
And I think we look at this idea of uh,
this drug,
especially psychedelic drugs,
right?
We look at the idea as some sort of escape or some sort of a forbidden fruit or
some sort of thing.
I think that's just because they're supposed to be respected.
I think if you experience them and understand what they're really about,
it's,
it's a lot different than it looks like from the outside.
I can see the nobility in your desire to get there on your own right,
to use meditation and clear headed thinking.
You've obviously thought a lot.
You're very bright guidance,
you know,
it's cool to have you on the show,
but why thank you.
There's a big difference between that and the psychedelic experience aside.
Totally agree.
So insanely,
infinitely humbling.
So W I would not,
I would not disagree with you on that,
but why I wouldn't you?
How come you're unwilling to allow them?
Because I think there is something insanely humbling about seeking the purity of
my own essence through no external a device other than my own concentration.
And that has worth to me that in so far as my life choices in my life
directions,
which is just as valid as doing it and I would never dissuade someone to or from
the choice to do it or not do it.
This has been a,
uh,
a direct choice I have made of my life to see who I am through my own brain.
Because ultimately what what they do is,
um,
not alter your brain [inaudible] but ultimately release it.
And I think that release is still available to you without it.
Now,
uh,
people may disagree with me on that and they're welcome to,
but I have,
if you can get to mushrooms on your own,
good fucking luck kind of conceptually.
Yeah.
You haven't found out who you are yet though,
right?
So you're searching for yourself.
You're searching for to find out who you are.
You haven't found that yet to cue up the who right now,
who are you throw that shit on.
You want to put some real music on for Brian to that shit up.
So then she had on youtube,
so that's get something for the youngsters.
So people want to understand the purity of expression.
The WHO,
what,
who are you,
motherfucker?
Huh?
Yeah.
How dare you use two hands to type.
This is implied.
Never listened to the WHO.
Oh,
I'm actually sung with Roger Daltrey.
Dude,
there was an,
there's a concert.
This is all legend by the way.
There was a concert that they did did the whose performance was so bad acid.
The rolling
stones didn't want the video of it released and find the who blew them off the
stage and at a song.
How do you not know this song?
Cause it was on the radio.
You would have to be from another fucking planet if you didn't know this song.
Yeah.
You have to be something wrong with you.
If you smoke two hits of the stuff that I smoke and you did and you hear this,
they didn't have the Internet back then.
Okay.
This is during black and white TVS motherfucker.
The real shit
does a lot like a studio video talks.
They just got it right man.
It's damn a donor.
That's who he looks just like nine feet,
eight towns and once impaled his own hand on his whammy bar during that big
really?
Yeah.
Hand flair is that whammy bar gets stuck in the up position.
Show him outright
shit.
That must be terrifying for a guitarist.
What's his right hand?
I mean you'd manage you,
but you're left handed.
I mean,
I broke my ring finger on my,
on my phone breading hand.
Just one of the scariest things that ever happened to me because of my ring
finger at your bending thinker.
It's the root of all your cords.
One,
I made a decision when it happened because that's three screws in it now.
Whoa.
I made a decision that it would make me a better guitar player.
I didn't know how at the time,
but I made that decision.
I remember the Django Reinhardt who played with two fingers and,
and uh,
Tom Tony Iommi who doesn't have the tips on his fingers.
And I'm like,
if,
if those fuckers can find their way to being that important guitar wise,
I can find my way back from this.
Huh.
And,
uh,
I ended up doing all the Solos on my first record with this broken finger.
My old boxing coach,
Joe Lake,
he got his finger bitten off in a street fight.
So he had his toe removed,
his second toe,
not the big one,
the second toe.
Sure.
And permanently curved like this so that he could throw a right hook.
He had a tremendous rate hook.
Wow.
So where his index finger is,
he has a a toe and it's permanently curved because you know,
they couldn't just,
you know,
have it move,
like they just kind of make this immediate hook thing.
Whereas finger used to be,
and he had it permanently like this.
So he punched my,
when I,
when I first got the finger fixed,
they told me it would never been passed there.
It would always be stuck kind of bad as far as it go.
It would go,
and I have full articulation in it because I did acupuncture.
Oh,
that was the trick.
Acupuncture did it.
Yep.
Hmm.
Make,
gave me full flexibility in it.
My friend Paul Broca has his broke,
his window is closed in his window and the window shattered and his hand went
through the glass and it's severed the tendons on the last three fingers of his
hand.
Jesus.
And he went through a bunch of operations,
but they couldn't get it right.
He just kept it stayed bent no matter what he did.
So his last three fingers were basically constantly closed.
Yeah.
My friend Andy had that same thing where his ring is [inaudible] he's a guitar
player too,
is a pinky on that from fingers just instantly like that.
And you never noticed when you're talking to,
because a lot of times when he's playing you're like,
oh,
he's just,
that's how he plays or something.
Pretty fascinating.
The,
uh,
the innovation they're making right now with artificial limbs and you know,
totally do it if we don't even know the,
yeah.
That's really exponentially exploding.
You know,
it's,
it's so fascinating.
The concept of an artificial body is only like a few decades away.
Totally.
You know,
it's really,
really pretty fucking scary times,
you know,
I didn't,
I don't know.
I think it's,
you know,
I mean,
not Pfizer,
just,
just exciting I should say.
Yeah.
Like,
Whoa,
fuck is happening.
Yeah,
totally.
Well,
we,
we can't even picture it,
which is kind of amazing.
We are literally pre-cellphone phone humans,
uh,
about like bionic technology and stuff.
And I'm for it.
I'm a big fan of a longevity.
I'm a big fan of that.
You know,
the Harvard longevity products,
the hundred year lifespan concept and you know,
like they're really working.
Yeah.
But people have to die.
Okay.
Here's the part,
here's the problem with that.
Nobody wants to start over from scratch as a baby again,
but you might have to,
okay.
Right.
Cause this,
the deal is we can't go on forever.
There's too fucking many of us.
We already lives forever.
How we get off plan,
this is the,
this is how we get off planet because you need a thousand year lifespan,
otherwise you can't get to the next galaxy.
That's,
and so that's essentially why re once you really believe that that's what's
happening.
Yeah.
That if you're going to get a spaceship to leave the earth and go to Andromeda
are the next big star that has livable planets next to it of which they found 47
in the last year.
Um,
then you're going to have to have a life span at least exceeding 250 years.
And the ironic part,
and my cousin,
I always talk about this,
that if you have a ship leaves right now headed to a drama with people who can
live to be 250 years old.
By the time they get halfway there,
we'll have doubled the technology and doubled our lifespan to the point where we
will actually meet them there.
And the question will always be,
do you stop and pick them up?
You just planned a party when they arrive but the trip.
But um,
that's just the nature of how technology goes.
They said the first person to live to be 250 is alive right now and probably 15
years old.
Well,
you know,
here's the other issue though.
What if there's another form of space travel that we're just not aware of?
I agree.
I think this idea of shooting rockets through spaces just I think cases,
old school man,
that's how I agree.
Sundial.
I agree.
Well at that point,
age doesn't matter because you're actually referentially in times in space time
you're in,
every place is going to matter.
Your biological system can only stay alive for a certain amount of cycles.
You know,
there's going to be,
it's going to be an end to it,
a certain amount of heartbeats that has on the meter.
Sure.
But you might be able to generate another one with your own stem cells or who
and move into it.
There's all kinds of,
yeah,
that's the thing.
You might be able to generate countless copies of yourself.
So just say,
we haven't done that.
We've just decided to paint them in other ways.
I mean the concept of a soulmate,
what's the difference between that and somebody you share a soul with?
That's a one being with two bodies do have obviously never been divorced.
You don't even know what the fuck you're talking about.
There's a huge difference.
That means that bitch is trying to get your money.
They had nothing to do with soul's.
You guys aren't connected anymore,
right?
Soulmates split up.
Well,
no,
what I'm saying is all bitterness aside,
uh,
no doubt earned.
Um,
it's the,
is kind of like when in a fish
tank,
if you look through it,
if you stuck your fingers into a fish tank to the fish,
it sees five different cylinders that are not attached.
But if you keep pushing your hand and you realize that they're all from the same
thing.
And so on a three dimensional world,
you could actually have one so old that had several different expressions in
this three d world,
and we only experienced them as kind of like those cylinders.
And once we see past that,
then we can see that actually one soul may live.
You may be one of 15 different versions of you in this life right now.
There may be,
uh,
Chinese peasant version of you in a row,
rich Russian version of you and all these running around learning all your
lessons at once because time doesn't really matter and you chose.
And each time,
it's like when you play a video game the first time you play one level,
but then later on you get several games and you're like,
you're doing what you're doing call of duty on one thing.
And you'd go back to it later,
but you want to play this new game for awhile and eventually you get a higher
order.
Sort of thinking with that stuff when you initially started out with just this,
I think we grow and evolve like that.
That's some serious speculation though.
Of course.
It is speculating that there's a bunch of user running around living alternate
lives.
Yeah.
Mm.
You know,
I think more likely,
more likely that the whole concept of all of us,
the whole concept of you and I and it's just horse shit.
It's just a trick.
It's like cubicles.
It's like you're all,
we're all working on our little cubicle and eventually there's going to be some
things,
something,
whether it's a technological achievement,
whether it's another advance in evolution,
some new new ability that we're going to detect,
we're,
we're going to have rather
I could,
I would call that graduation.
I think this is,
I think this universe,
I think we overreact to the earth.
I think we're too impressed and I think earth is like third to fifth grade in
the universal growth scape things and I think we come here as third graders and
ultimately and leave as fifth graders.
What do you,
what we think is fixed by the earth that,
what do you mean by that?
I mean we're overwhelmed by the experience that we have here and when we think
it's the be all end all and that this is where all the evolution will happen for
your soul and your spirit that you,
there's not another place beyond this that might be at a higher resonance,
whether it's another galaxy or another dimension.
If you want to use earth type terms or you just remove yourself and go,
I don't,
that's earth ends up being a movie you watched for several lifetimes that you
learned and you were entertained by,
but it has nothing to do with your actual existence.
You just gain information from it while you're here,
but it's not the evolution of humankind.
Once it sort of happens,
the purpose of this place sort of ends.
It's like,
you know you leave college,
you don't evolve college.
You know what you mean by that
purpose,
this place being civilization,
not earth itself.
No,
no,
no.
As human beings the not,
I mean the earth itself are our expression in the earth plane so it's like our
future
is somewhere else.
Do you think it's in another galaxy?
I mean I think those are earth based terms.
We can't even wrap our head around because we come here.
I think intentionally limiting our experiential life.
We,
we come in Chile intentionally.
We come here to eliminate the same way that when you go see a movie,
you don't think about the rest of the world outside the movie.
You think about,
you sit,
you commit to sitting in the dark and a theater with your ass in a chair and
that's a total limitation of who you are as an ex,
as a human being.
You could run and jump and sing and play guitar and fight and do all this shit,
but you say no.
Right now what I want to do is experience this.
So I'm going to shut all that stuff out.
Because if I did it,
I'd be a toddler in a fucking movie theater,
irritating everyone,
which is why we kill those people.
Why Jesus's?
There's basically like the one running around going and you can laugh and dance
and sing here and we're like,
shut the fuck up.
We're trying to watch the movie because I'm here to learn this.
There's an element of,
and there's,
there's value to those people coming and going.
You guys do realize this is just a movie.
Okay,
so calm down.
There's those guys are helpful.
But to a certain point they interrupt the movie.
So we tend to go fuck off.
Um,
but what I'm saying is,
is that this earth,
this space,
this,
I mean it might just be,
it might be the entire universe,
the entire span of the human existence from cell,
you know,
single cell life form to when we colonize other planets might be us going
through middle school as spirits.
And when we graduate from that,
it's not that the earth becomes like,
Oh,
we've,
you know,
we've reached this point,
we reach a point and then we pop out and it starts from scratch and a cycle for
new spirits to grow into that thing,
you know,
each,
each round.
And so we leave and go somewhere else.
Yeah.
That's the idea or that,
or if there is,
you know,
somewhere is again,
uh,
a spacial concept,
right?
So it's not,
so you might go someone else frequency,
we might go somewhere else somewhere else,
you know.
But uh,
conceptually,
uh,
I think what we do is when we get to exaggerate too caught up in the earth plane
existence,
we go,
the whole human race has to reach a pinnacle belief.
It's an Armageddon thought for them in a positive or negative sense.
We have to evolve to a point we'll,
maybe we do as individuals or as it's an as an expression of a soul here.
And then we just stopped that expression and go someplace else because we've
learned what this place has to teach us.
The same way you enter middle school,
you don't change middle school by the time you leave,
you just get to eight grade and go,
I don't need middle school anymore.
I'm ready for high school.
And that doesn't devalue middle school.
It's still important.
It's gravely important.
It's great.
It's important to your social factor is great.
Important to your w the learning that's inbetween rudimentary and advanced.
It's got a point but it's not the whole point.
And if you go,
life begins and end in middle school and if we don't always get all these sixth
graders together,
we got to fucking win this.
Or you know,
all the high schools.
Do you propose not concentrating on the present,
maybe,
what do you know?
No,
I think that's what your goal is and that's how you grow.
To just live in the present.
Yeah.
And own that self and just so not,
not be attached to the idea of the earth.
Not Be attached to the idea of this existence.
Yeah.
Just kind of go through it.
Well,
no,
I mean you enjoy it while you're here.
You have to,
I mean,
I,
I'm a believer in using it.
This is all speculation,
right?
Of course it is.
It's supposed to be.
So if I knew it,
I wouldn't have to be here.
No,
but what I was going to say is,
it's interesting how the same speculative
speculative ideas keep coming back and forth from like ancient eastern
mysticism,
you know,
to the idea of reincarnation,
right?
Idea of,
you know,
the Kali Yoga,
the ages of the,
it's like,
it's almost like all these different philosophies throughout history have all
come upon the same ideas over and over and over again.
It's like they just,
they get to a certain point where enough people are thinking where they put
enough shit written down so that enough people can learn from the past shit and
then they pile up like to the top of this pyramid of understanding and they all
come to like the same sort of conclusion.
Yeah.
I think,
well,
I think there are two sort of sets.
There's the mechanical sets.
Most real religious,
uh,
sex have sort of an esoteric teaching tradition,
which is the higher order.
You're only allowed to know the secrets once you get to a certain point,
which we all understand.
It's the gated community of,
of,
of spirituality.
You get it,
you got,
it's controlled.
You got will.
You do have to do some work though.
Yeah it is.
But it's like the idea behind it is wrong.
You know that,
you know,
whenever you get people in a position of power that are just holding back
information that I agree,
but I also think there's,
there's,
there may be some value in and going,
you know,
your resident body isn't ready to take this yet and I'm not just going to hand
it over to you.
You got to earn it.
Well,
I think,
yeah,
yeah.
Well there's something to that on your own for your own good human beings,
you know,
developing discipline and learning how to appreciate intelligence and
[inaudible].
Exactly.
Yeah.
And I think that's the essence of where it starts now.
Now that's the only power grab later that all that being said,
I think sort of the esoteric traditions that you'll find in any,
in any kind of higher order thinking come from a level of discipline and the
idea of discipline,
which is okay because eventually you go,
why am I here?
What am I actually attempting to do here on a cellular or soul level?
Also discipline I think is his maintenance.
It's a maintenance,
um,
sort of a strategy that you can run on your body and keeping your body in a
state where it doesn't fuck with you and doesn't give you a unnecessary
information and stays flat and clean,
keeps it focused in the present.
You're,
if you don't understand hard work and you don't understand like physical
limitations,
you know your dream.
If you don't,
if you've never pushed your endurance and broken yourself,
if you've never been,
then you're not going to know how your body responds and how much of totally
what you do in life is mental.
How much of what you do in life is about your attitude and maintaining a certain
point of focus in a certain way of thinking and a certain resonance of thinking
while that's developed or discipline.
I agree it really good at something and it's really hard.
You work hard at it.
What is the gym but manufactured adversity.
You create an adverse situation that was not there.
These things,
these heavy things do not need to be lifted off the ground right now,
but in the future I may have to deal with that and in the past I have and I'm
aware of those moments where I was at the edge of my experience and I need to
boot beyond that for me to be happy and grow.
So I specifically take time to focus in this moment,
take
advert,
potential adversity in past adversity and focus it in this moment.
Go,
I'm going to go to the gym and lift more weight than I've ever lifted before so
that if my body is called to do such a thing,
I'm able to do it comfortably so that I can focus on the higher order element of
it so that the next time I lived 250 pounds,
I'm not going fuck do it.
And 50 pounds,
I'm lifting 250 pounds and I'm focusing on my breath or I'm focusing on my
growth or my strength and or,
or the amount of times I can do it as opposed to everything is hard the first
time.
Um,
so we set up these situations where we are intentionally creating an adverse
experience.
There's no,
you don't have to go to the gym and work out.
You don't have to eat better.
You don't have to do that.
You Go,
all right,
I'm going to quell my own set.
I'm going to discipline my own relaxation reflex because I want to accomplish
anything.
And I think the earth is very similar.
I think spirits create a manufactured adversity.
We create this space which is hard to get through,
that has its challenges and sometimes we make it through and sometimes we fail
and we go back again and again until we get past these lessons and then we
become a higher resident being and we moved to another level of growth that may
not be in space time.
For example.
Is this something you were attached to?
Um,
no.
So No.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean,
I'm like,
are you convinced that this is how it goes?
This is how life goes.
Feels right,
feels right.
Yeah.
Sometimes to me it feels like the whole thing is really a mathematical equation
and that math is a language,
the entire existence of,
of the universe,
everything that every little thing is happening and every little action that
happens on earth,
animals,
eating animals,
water pollution,
farms,
emotions,
sex,
drugs,
rock and roll,
all of it together,
each moment and each thing are a part of a gigantic intangible algorithm.
And that everything that has ever happened to you and everything that's ever
happened to anyone that you'll ever meet and anything that's ever happened
that's all connected together.
All of it is all moving the human race towards one direction.
Much like a caterpillar becomes a butterfly and isn't even aware of what the
fuck is stone and gets inside the cocoon.
Sure.
That everything we're doing is moving us into some new direction.
Everything from the beginning to now is moving us into some,
I mean,
if you look at what people are really concentrating on right now at the highest
levels of science,
it's the heart of matter.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
the large hedge funds of the universe.
Yeah.
Right.
The edges of the universe,
the heart of matter,
the,
you know,
the creation of artificial black holes,
the idea of time travel.
We're really getting into the meat of things.
Sure.
But,
um,
in many ways,
early human societies thought they were getting to the meat of things and it
just became a new blossoming level,
became a new grade as it were in that school.
You know what I mean?
Society's,
yeah.
Right.
But early societies,
if they were constantly searching for new things and constantly trying to
innovate and constantly trying come up with the next new invention,
which they always were,
they're building towards something.
It's,
it's this,
this thirst for innovation.
At a certain point in time it doesn't become a matter of what makes your life
easier.
Innovation becomes a matter of what else can we do,
can we do this?
And it becomes almost like a life of its own instead of you creating things to
help people.
The,
the getting interested in fascinated about these various things.
People say,
well that's how everything gets made and how we have all these advances in
science and medicine and you know,
we can help people.
It's all because of science.
You can't criticize science like no one's criticizing anything.
I'm absolutely not criticizing it,
but I'm sorry,
I'm just looking at it objectively like this idea that we're constantly trying
to come up with the newest,
greatest thing and this,
this idea where we're trying to constantly get to the heart of everything that
the heart of matter,
the the milliseconds after the big bang.
Like that's not going to stop.
That's going to keep going.
The,
you know the interesting thing about that mill,
that Big Bang theory was that they reckon they a w I think it was like two weeks
ago,
it came up with this new postulate that seems to be mathematically sound,
that the big bang was not the beginning of anything but another wave in a series
of similar actions and that it,
there was no first beginning that there were many beginnings and it comes in
tides and what we are as human beings,
we're we're plankton who think that every wave is our whole life and thinking
that,
oh,
this waves began when it crested and dies when it hits the shore,
when it's just a,
that same water is reused again and again in an infinite series of waves and
that those plankton live and die in that period until they evolve past a point
where they can do the crawl up on shore,
go out to C and B,
and then their experience becomes longer.
Now my experience on the shore is waves come and hit me every four and I have a
lifespan where five waves hit me or I'm out in the sea and I live five cycles,
you know?
And then I get more advanced and more advanced where I'm moving inland and I
never experienced the flow of the sea anymore.
I have to go back to the sea to recognize there's a cycle at all.
Cause I live in land and now it's weather patterns that are months and months
long and then years and then you know,
as you grow into that span,
and I think right now we're,
we're,
we're that again and again and we,
and it's millennia for us,
but in terms of what life could be,
it's that,
mm.
I think our biological need to stay alive,
our instincts to survive,
our instincts,
to think that we are special,
we are important.
We do matter because if we didn't matter,
and if you do look at yourself in the great picture of things and go,
God,
this is all meaningless.
This is pointless.
This is,
you know,
this is,
this is no need for me to even be paying attention here.
Yeah,
no,
you know what I'm saying?
It's,
um,
the idea being that,
you know,
we are this biological entity that does need to stay alive,
but we are aware of how ridiculous that all is all at the same time.
And it's a very conflicting existence.
We have this hardware that is basically the same shit we were using.
We were throwing sticks at woolly mammoths.
I mean,
basically that was 11,000 years ago.
We had the same hardware then as we have now.
That's true.
But we were using,
we're using greater and greater percentages of it.
What do you mean by that
brain pan?
Uh,
we still use,
you know,
we're looking at 6% of the human brain.
You're looking at cro magnon man using about three.
Yeah.
But is that all right?
Because you know cro-magnon man neanderthal rather had a larger brain than we
did.
Yeah.
And it was dumber than we are.
Right.
But cows have a bigger brain than we do to,
and that he is what,
yeah.
Fortunately though they don't.
Sure.
But,
but intellectually it's,
it's not what you have in the brain pan area.
It's how much of it you can use and to what coordination.
But it's really synaptic firing between different areas that court that make it
happen.
Right.
But that whole,
you only use 6% of your brain thing.
I don't think it's essential.
Essentially.
I don't think that science,
I think what that is is a misunderstanding of what the brain does.
And we don't really know well,
we're just sort of guessing like there's,
there was some fucking posts that I put up as a study on conservatives.
There's a certain area of conservatives brains that deals with fear that is
larger than on their,
their liberal counterpoints.
Just fascinating.
So I put this,
of course,
a fucking hundred thousand dudes.
You are sold Fulcan Daum you don't,
your goddamn liberal reacted fearfully.
There's one dude sent me like 15 tweets in a row.
By the way,
I'm more of a Republican than I am a democrat.
I would vote for Ron Paul in a heartbeat for president.
I believe in that guy.
Well,
he is.
I mean,
he might not be,
but he is,
he's an old school republican,
you know what I'm saying?
He's a legit conservative.
Okay.
Definitely the fucking guy doesn't even believe in,
I mean he's a creationist,
he's a legit conservative,
but yet I support him.
I support that guy and his ideas more than I do.
Uh,
most liberals who want to just throw money at things,
you know,
I think you look at it,
it from a,
just a natural perspective of evolution like that the issue isn't throwing money
at things.
Know
money,
just tension.
Yeah.
Money's just and disen dis uh,
affected attention basically.
Um,
what we used to do is keep grandma at home and give her our attention in person.
Now there is a way I can give her my attention without having to be there at the
time so I can pay for her to be in a home where other people are paid to give
her attention,
meaning feed her clothes,
her wash her,
provide all this thing and that's money is our way of going.
Look,
I can't give you my genuine emotional attention.
I have gathered a pile of attention and I can give you some of it in this way,
but I can't do it from here.
It's not practical and I have people in my life that actually deserve that at a
higher level.
My actual personal attention and money,
money's just,
it's an intermediary.
It has no worth except ideas and,
and,
well,
I mean it does mean this does a lot of things.
I know,
but it does.
It does whatever you want it to do because it's where you put your
right.
But what I think what we're talking about though is taxes or talking about what
is the,
you know,
Democrats versus Republicans that they believed that the Democrats want to throw
more money at.
Sure.
Also,
what do you think your attention needs to go to?
Real issue is not that the real issue is not where they throw in the money.
The real issue is where are you getting money from?
The we're real issue is who the fuck is financing your campaigns?
Who are you really beholden to once you get into office?
Are you really acting for the individual?
Because you know you're not,
you're not,
you're not really the United corporations of America is what it is.
That's,
that's really what it is.
And the corporation,
the this distraction of tax cuts in this and that.
And the real issue is if we were involved in these gigantic wars and we just
instead spent the same amount of money fixing up the ghettos,
Jesus fucking Christ,
we could fix everything in your January,
we would have no problem.
We will have zero zero crime if you went to you and take the trillions of
dollars we spend on this war and just create social programs where you hire
people who are like experienced counselors who are really educated and pay them
a good salary.
So it's a,
it's a nice job and help help them with kids that are fatherless and you know,
develop community after school programs.
That's not fucking rockets.
Going to Afghanistan.
It's way cheaper than that total.
All this can be done.
All this can be done if you wanted to really fix the world,
that's the way to do it.
I totally agree.
These cots in their tax cuts,
you're missing everything.
That's not what it all is,
where you put it,
it's right where you need a totally new way of looking at the whole thing.
You know,
we need to look at the whole thing is we really are all the same thing.
And just because that guy is over there,
it doesn't mean he's not connected to you.
Interestingly enough.
Um,
that's the way the vast majority of the world is going thought form wise.
And uh,
it,
uh,
the ruling elite and who have been in power for quite some time are dealing with
that fact and they're not happy about it.
But if you look at even statistical trends in life expectancy and family size,
which used to be the big fear that uh,
you know,
first world nations,
long life,
small families,
third world nations,
short life,
big families,
this used to be that.
And that was the big fear.
Here comes the march of the poor people.
This is what's going to happen statistically over the,
since the 1970s,
it's,
you can even watch the graph.
There's a guy on a ted conference who showed,
who does an animated graph of,
of where it's going.
And it used to be exactly that.
India,
China,
um,
the,
the south,
Southeast Asian in general,
Africa.
It was all this like low lifespan way down here and uh,
and lots of kids.
And then over here in the West,
very few to kids or less and long lifespans and everybody is marching this
direction.
Hmm.
Everybody worldwide,
Africa to India,
to China.
Everybody's going smaller families longer lives.
And this is,
this is,
uh,
and it's unquestionable.
It's,
it's shocking to look at how fast because as much as the population bloomed,
we look at those graphs and go,
Holy Shit,
look at all the new people.
The shift back,
the other direction is really impressive.
Natures of mother Fucker,
Dude.
You know,
the,
the complex structure of all the things it's going on behind the scenes.
It's so fascinating.
It'll tell,
it'll,
it'll tell you how to be.
We were talking about,
um,
you know about the,
uh,
the concept of a attacks berm from when we did the show blocking sperm.
They also have the ones that run in your Ference.
Yeah,
fighting sermon.
So much shit going on behind the scenes and we're just running around living our
lives as if we're in control.
Like you're,
you are in control of like the eyeballs.
You got the steering wheel behind the eyeballs,
all the shit that's going on down there.
You literally,
you can move it.
You have no idea what the fuck is happening inside.
You don't have a clue what you're,
yeah.
Holds and nations,
your,
your consciousness is probably a,
you know,
a mile percentage of your existence,
of your actual sole existence,
your metaphysical existence because it couldn't be,
you couldn't have it all here at once or it would just be overwhelming.
You would just blast light out of every sale or something because everything
would be so alive and so full of consciousness at the same time to just a trip
to think that you contain a bunch of different life forms inside your body,
like bacterias and right,
and you need them to stay alive.
That's just nuts in and of itself.
Whole ecosystems inside your body,
right.
It's like when people get like,
like,
I want to be cremated.
I don't want be food for magnets and be like,
dude,
you realize how many living things are eating your skin cells right now,
and if they didn't,
you would suffocate.
Yeah.
What you're doing is just being a greedy.
Fuck.
It's right.
You know you don't want to play,
you know,
like you,
you have to leave.
So you unplug the Atari and you take it with you,
right?
Exactly.
Yeah.
Let it melt into the ground with that bacteria.
Eat it.
That's what he's there for.
Exactly.
It's assistant up and said,
no,
we got to wrap it in a steel box.
Half the time,
those,
those habits came because we didn't know when people were dead.
We thought,
calm is an accident.
You know that stillness was death,
so we would bury people who are still alive.
That's where the bells in cemeteries come from.
They used to have a bell in a cemetery.
She literally was tied to your string in a string to your finger through a tube
that went down there.
And if you rank,
if you were alive in the cosmetic,
fucking come out and dig your ass up.
Crazy.
But the reason we built harder and harder caskets,
it's cause we were terrible at telling who was dead.
Oh my God.
They still fuck up every now and then.
There's still the Internet story of someone who thought some old lady was dead.
She pops back.
Oh,
it's gotta be Spaghetti.
Ton of fun.
Mortality,
man.
That's the motherfucker.
That's what everybody's afraid of.
That's no one wants to talk about the inevitable end of the trip,
right?
I mother fucker dude.
Yeah,
but doesn't it make you know all the rest of it?
A lot more tasty.
It does a gas,
if you can really intellectualize it,
if he could really wrap your head around it.
But most of us can't.
I don't think I can.
I don't know.
I pretend to be able to wrap my head around it,
but the end,
really,
it's when it comes,
we're all going to be white knuckled and shit in our pants.
There's no doubt about it,
man.
You know?
No,
I've seen like I've seen some people go through the transition as it were,
if you want to call it that.
And I've seen people die and I've like,
uh,
it's,
it's an,
it's not always that experience.
You know what,
hear that story about the same Kanutson remember when Sam died?
He,
uh,
he was laying there and he goes,
why?
He was saying why now,
why now?
He was looking at somebody in the distance and he said,
And then he finally went,
oh,
I see.
Okay.
Yeah.
Thank God.
And you know about DMT,
right?
Sure.
The brain releasing it and upon the will,
theoretically releasing the great moments of great stress or the,
at the moment of human death,
you know,
there's no reason why that would be an evolutionary change.
That would be a consciousness choice,
but it would not be an evolutionary she has because nobody lives past that
point.
So you wouldn't develop,
that's a gateway.
That's a chemical gateway into the next stage,
right?
That it's,
that helps you kick the body away and move on.
The thing about the DMT experience is they talk to,
they talk to you a lot.
They say all kinds of crazy shit to you and they say things to you in a language
that you don't really hear you.
You just know exactly what the words are.
The words like appear in front of your face and you know they're saying it
right.
It's very,
very tricky.
But it's the type of thing that you say,
well if a guy was dying and as he's telling,
he starts talking,
well that guy is tripping.
That's what that is.
Right.
You know,
and then the question comes up,
is it real or is it just,
is he on drugs?
You know,
is it all just nonsense and is the idea of Nope,
cause it just sexy.
You know,
the idea that biologic on a purely biological level,
there is no reason for that to exist because again,
nobody's made what stinks.
Nobody mates after that point.
And there's no service to the actual life form to let it go peacefully.
If anything,
the opposite is true.
If a life at at the end of its life,
if it,
oh,
it was just about biology,
what you would do is flip out,
you would be like pris in uh,
in blade runner.
You just kind of wiggle and freak out because that's all that matters is get
back to life,
right biologically.
Cause that's the only way you would live to mate again.
Right?
And pass on that trait to anyone else.
But if you have an end of life experience that softens the experience and brings
you someplace else,
that's a chemical expression,
which by the way is just energy and information that comes from consciousness
anyways.
You create through your,
you know,
there's no route to consciousness.
There's no,
you can't find it and cut it out of the brain doesn't happen.
Right?
You can cut the expression out of the brain,
the ability to express it like movement and speech,
but you can't take the thing itself away.
Can't look under a petri dish and say this is where thought is.
Well,
you know,
the idea of it being non local,
it's like a deep proc show,
Oprah,
right idea.
He's always pimping of the idea of,
I shouldn't say Cummins,
nice guy.
Uh,
the idea that you know,
that consciousness is like something that's out there outside of it and your
body is sort of a vessel for it holds its cutting loose comfortably because
you're,
you're going from a totally different,
it's like coming out of surgery where they give you painkillers.
They would need to,
or you would flip out if there's something on the other side going,
look,
we got it.
He's going to be in so much pain coming out of this experience into the new
experience of being healed and different.
Um,
we've got,
there's got to be a transition between the two.
So they give you pain medication when you're coming out of anesthesia and we'll
know at the
beginning,
like when you're,
when you're back at you,
a lot of people after they're waking up,
they'll get them right on pain medications essentially,
so that when they're,
you know,
they're waking up,
they're not in horrible pain.
Oh,
okay.
So,
um,
in essence,
that's what the DMT would serve.
If you are looking at it from a consciousness standpoint is that you're moving
from the earth plane to a non earth plane.
Um,
or you're just getting fucked up on drugs is nice little treat.
Here you go.
Life's over.
Go for a ride.
The last trip.
Exactly.
But why would you treat yourself like that?
You Bud has got some leftover shit.
Just keep this dude's dying.
Give him a,
give him a shot.
See,
but it would do the job
well.
A lot of people when they're dying,
they get hard ons too.
That's true.
There's some sort of a disease.
Like we're,
we're as guys are dying.
God Damn it.
What is it?
There's something where,
where men as they're dying,
uh,
regularly get erections right before death.
And I don't know what it's dying of MFA.
I believe some sort of poison perhaps.
Fuck me.
I hate not knowing this shit,
but I don't know.
I'm familiar with this.
But it happens and it's almost like your body is like
one last chance,
right?
Like your body knows
it's over.
Your body is like dealing with an overwhelming,
you know,
number of things shutting down.
Yeah.
Liver shutting down.
Boss was losing the,
we'll lose central nervous system,
pressure shift,
fire up the deck,
go out and go play.
So glory.
You know your body just fucking every fucking burn up.
All right.
Get getting the balls.
Boys.
Find somebody.
He just as the moment,
the moment of death.
Your Dick is hard as a crowbar.
Just hoping some hor spots it and just dives on it real quick.
Right.
I bet it's happened somewhere along the line.
It's probably been in
just write,
it might've been,
um,
you know,
part of the sex rights of,
of,
you know,
higher tradition.
There's a lot of whores out there.
If there's a hard dick in front of them,
they'll just hop on it.
They can't help themselves.
There's a lot of girls who liked that,
especially thousands and thousands of years ago back when they didn't even have
written language.
Yeah,
of course.
It just dive on Dick.
So it'd be like made them horse then.
Well it just horse,
they just are.
No,
they're not.
They're just dive in on Dixon versions.
They might not even know that guy that might be nurses.
They might be in the room while he's crying,
paid what you mean is slut and sluts and eliminate some.
That as a concept eliminates the choice on the woman's part that she said,
I'm out broken and doesn't derive pleasure from it or whatever.
It makes
fascinating concept,
but in Spain they force prostitutes to start wearing yellow reflective vests
because too many of them were getting hit by cars
because you know they hang out in this a head pick up.
That's hilarious because prostitution is legal in Spain.
Yeah.
They forced these chicks and micro set everybody like look at for a good with it
and then reflect your vest and a helmet and God,
yeah.
You mentioned getting a blow job from a chick with a reflective vest.
A fuck is wrong.
Low for the cone zone.
Who's sitting there as the cars drive by and the lights from their head lights
flash off that reflective vest.
He started wondering about your choices or bad breath,
blow job,
stinking up your fucking car and you're like,
how many loads did she have fermenting in her mouth right now on how many
crossing get mistaken for hookers out there.
A lot.
Yeah,
they better where some low shoes crossing guards.
You know these to try to be all sexy and shit.
You can't pull that off into your heels are out.
No clear.
Here's for crossing gardens.
I'm glad we settled all this,
which is the good part.
You know,
we fucking locked it all down.
Dude was a lot of confusion when we started this podcast.
I think a lot of has been cleared.
A lot of apprehension.
A lot of concern.
Nervousness.
Yeah man.
About,
yeah.
You know whether or not we're here for any particular reasons.
You know,
an interesting thing to talk about and speculate,
but ultimately the most important thing is the quality of the experience.
While you're here,
you know,
have fun while you're here.
I agree.
That's because it can be fun.
That is the one thing that you can control.
That here can be fun.
If you surround yourself with cool people,
if you surround yourself with positive people,
you do what you're supposed to be doing in life,
you know,
find a path that makes you feel happy.
You can ultimately,
you can have,
this can be a good goddamn time.
Absolutely.
That's why we need directions.
You know,
we need like someone needs to like help people figure out from the right
something like the Georgia stones,
those,
those fucking,
those um,
you ever seen those things?
There's like the,
they call it the Georgia Stonehenge,
but uh,
the Georgia wisdom stones or something like that and it's a,
it was in the 1970 somebody had it constructed in 12 different languages in case
of an apocalypse.
There's these gigantic stone tablets with all these different directions on how
to,
uh,
live Georgia Guidestones I believe it is.
Oh,
nice.
Right.
Pull that shit up so you can Georgia.
Yeah,
yeah.
In the state of Georgia or the country of Georgia state in America.
Some guy who is a thing,
some on,
they don't know if it was,
they don't know exactly who he is because a,
uh,
was it again,
it was anonymous Georgia Guidestones that's cool.
It's fascinating.
Yeah.
And it's,
you know,
keep humanity to under 500 million people worldwide.
That's one of the,
one of the principals share,
which is a good one,
you know,
which is what an agoraphobic a millionaire who would make a bunch of Guidestones
would write with true.
But you know,
there is a certain amount of resources in a certain amount of people and when
the people go over the resources,
it's really not,
I would say get off planet then.
No.
Yeah,
but it's,
that's how that seems way harder than you're saying.
That seems like super,
super tired.
There's micro meteors out there,
there's 900,000 near Earth objects just between Mars and Jupiter.
Right.
And any one of them will just fuck you up.
You know,
you're just,
you're out there flying around in a big shoes to live at the basis of volcanoes
because it was warm,
like still doing Hawaii.
I know.
Shit.
You know what I mean?
In so far as culture,
we come a long way in that regard.
We're not,
you know,
there's a lot of shit on this planet that can fucking kill you randomly.
And then we're still out numbering everything.
I think it'd be be quicker to protect yourself and safer and more likely to
protect yourself from the shit that they can fuck you up here.
Except for the big ones like asteroid impacts,
they're separate.
One of the things you're gonna do is you're going to run into,
um,
life expansion that's going to out weigh the space.
And that's like saying,
look,
the ocean,
it's fucking dangerous.
Our boats,
our little brown things with paddles,
there's no fucking
way we're getting from Hawaii where there's lots of pineapple and everything is
fine.
As long as we have our little march to the top of the volcano and dump off done
the,
the useless people every once in awhile or you know,
uh,
a minor plague wipes out a decent number of us on a cycle.
We don't need to head to the other continents.
We don't need to express ourselves and find out what the rest of the earth is
like.
We have 98% of this world is unexplored in a lot of ways,
especially in the oceans.
Like we have no idea even hear what's going on.
And had we had that island mentality then we wouldn't be the expressions that we
are now.
And I think the same thing applies earth,
you know,
the,
this island earth concept.
You know,
why not,
man?
I don't know.
I just don't know if we're really going to be fucking flying through the galaxy
landed on new planets to starting up a new civilization.
Do you,
I mean,
think about how much of a variation in temperature we get on this planet.
Just a little bear.
The one between winter and summer and I was in Winnipeg and a student stand up
up there.
And uh,
whenever I'm in Canada,
I was asked people like,
hey,
how cold does it get here in the winter?
And the guy said 50 fucking degrees below zero 50.
Yeah.
Like just the idea that that can happen on this planet and the same planet were
an la at 70,
what is it in January 70?
Yeah.
What is it in February 70?
It's 70.
Go to Hawaii 80.
What is it in March 80?
What's an in July 80?
Sure.
Winnepeg minus 50.
Yeah.
And people have been living there or centuries.
I played in a theater that was like a couple hundred dollars.
What?
I mean,
so,
um,
but go back to human beings,
pre clothing and the winter comes wipes everybody the fuck.
Well,
they never know there they lived in Africa,
pre clothing almost.
Nobody ever really,
really was anywhere else.
Right?
Well,
we spread it and we spread out and a lot of people die and die.
I never get outside of the box.
We reached the limit of our physical experience.
What we could actually survive.
We got in,
we,
we made clothes.
Now we have these like reflective astronaut material that people can,
you know,
walk around and almost loose like jackets and almost that kind of weather and,
and be as warm as anybody wearing 16 animal pelts were,
you know,
uh,
300 years.
Did you see that?
They've found a new,
um,
into human evidence of the oldest human hundred 40,000 years old,
I think.
No,
no.
The one in Israel is more than that.
It's 400,000 year old,
right?
Homosapien the teeth.
Yeah.
It's fascinating.
Shit,
man.
They really don't even know how old along we've been around.
The real,
the hard part about it is when people don't understand is that it's not easy to
make a fossil.
Like things have to go wrong.
To make a fossil,
you have to get caught in a landslide.
Totally.
Like most of the time when you die,
things eat you and that's a wrap.
There's no bones left.
Like when we find dinosaurs or we find any fossilized animals,
it's because they died in someone.
Like there's some big thing that sealed them in,
right?
I mean,
you think about the mass of the earth and all the areas of,
of levels and levels of layers of dirt and how many things might be under there
that we're not even aware of was actually probably a bunch of species that we
haven't discovered yet.
Question,
including,
you know,
different,
different animals,
uh,
hominids.
You know,
they found that new new type of human being recently,
they believed there were several different branches of human brains that
interbred but they were totally different species.
Yeah.
Well they got the concept of modern man mating with neanderthals and the,
and the interesting thing was the male modern humans fucked neanderthal women.
Neanderthal men did not fuck modern women.
Wow.
Because it was a decision that it was like,
literally guys will fuck whoever and the women are like,
no fucking way.
I'm not going to let that asshole.
Fuck me.
And that was,
that was,
yeah,
that was like,
and if you look at the DNA strands,
it becomes increasingly clear that it was male modern humans who are fucking
neanderthal chicks.
And neanderthal.
Uh,
if this was anywhere around the same time alcohol was invented,
wonder if there was somehow your caucus,
the original,
you know,
could you imagine if that could be proven that the first guy to fucking knee and
Saul was hammered?
I was watching this fucking enlisting to country western,
right.
Just fucking sit in the back of his pickup truck,
cracking paps for rebuttal.
I'll think I'm going to fuck her.
Right.
Like that woman who,
who the other day do you hear about that one when he was like threatening
somebody with a knife?
Somebody's gonna eat my pussy or I'm going to kill somebody.
Why?
Yes.
Was Ready.
She was,
she was she,
she got arrested.
Where was that?
She had,
I don't know.
She had a knife and she was threatening these two guys.
One of them doesn't the eater and he think it was a Russian lady.
I want to say Russia.
They are my favorites wasn't here in America.
Yes.
We looked that up on Google.
I gotta take a Piss.
Do we have Jesus?
Hold on,
keep talking amongst yourself.
I'll be right back.
Coconut waters gate.
All right.
Great.
Cool.
How sparks getting up and go to the bathroom?
Ladies and gentlemen,
cover?
Um,
if somebody is going to eat my pussy or I'm going to cut your fucking throat.
That's what she said.
Her name was Melissa.
This is a a post on the Rogan board.
My message board from a man named shark,
not an excellent poster who posts many,
many quality things and I appreciate him very much.
And the picture,
this woman is fantastic and the name of the threat is someone's going to eat my
pussy or I'm going to cut your fucking throat.
And it says meet Melissa Lee Williams.
West Virginia woman 41 is facing assault and weapons charges after allegedly
waving a knife at two men who declined her demands to engage in sexual conduct
at a West Virginia Motor in
the October 22nd incident is detailed in an amusing gross.
Jackson County Sheriff's Department report IX excerpted here according to the
investigator's Williams who lives four doors down from her estranged husband at
the 77 motor inn showed up at his door and as Danny Williams and another man to
eat my pussy.
And quotes at this point,
William's pictured in the mugshot.
By the way,
if you haven't seen wonderful whites of
West Virginia,
this will be much more funny.
If you've seen that movie,
you've seen it,
right,
Brian?
Now.
Oh my God,
I've got a copy for you.
I've got a copy.
You've got two copies I bought.
Just hand handout sweet to people that don't have it.
Sweet.
It's fucking brilliant.
West Virginia,
man,
the you,
have you seen the wonderful whites of West Virginia?
All right.
You got one too.
I'll give you a copy of it too.
I got to car.
I buy copies just to give people cause it's so goddamn good.
Yeah.
When may have Miller was here,
I gave him a copy.
I've given a couple of people.
Eddie Bravo gave him a copy.
It's fucking the greatest documentary of all time.
It's just brilliant because it follows these people in West Virginia who are
basically savages.
They might as well be living in Liberia,
man.
It's just the,
uh,
West Virginia version of Africa.
Okay.
They're savage,
right?
Well,
the interesting thing that I've always said that time travel is totally fucking
possible if you just drive the right direction because literally you can drive
into New York City and be in the future.
Yeah.
And then you can drive to West Virginia in the mountains and be 150 years in the
fucking past man or in a totally different reality.
Like I've always heard that the apocalypse is here.
It just hasn't reached your door yet.
There's a lot of spots in the world really.
A comes and goes and little flare in Afghanistan.
Tell me the apocalypse isn't there,
Tom.
It's not there.
If you're a fucking soldier in Afghanistan right now,
tell me it's not there.
Tell me it's not there if you're in,
I rented.
That place hasn't changed in exactly,
but still the apocalypse.
If you had to live there right now,
well,
the apocalypse you imagine if you were out in the goat through the fucking the
mountains.
Yeah.
Armageddon.
Apocalypse is a difference.
Apocalypses when things shall be revealed,
it literally means a,
a vision really pack a lot.
It was like the end.
Know the where it's Armageddon is the end and the bottom club Armageddon comes
forward harm again,
which is a mountain in Israel where the,
the uh,
Israeli soldiers will stage the final battle to take back the,
uh,
the,
the mosque.
That's Aaron rebuild the temple of the mountain.
I'll sparks dropping knowledge.
Pictures.
You didn't know about all this.
I had no idea.
I always equated Armageddon and apocalypse to be basically the same thing.
Just as nonsensical idea.
That one is the one we're going to end once.
The happy ones,
the dark,
but they,
they're not,
they don't talk her dark.
They don't Armageddon.
Armageddon is the battle.
That's the battle which the apocalypse is.
When is after the four horsemen ride and God reveals himself four horsemen.
So you know that Unicorns are in the Bible.
King James Bible Unicorns.
Wow.
Somebody put that on the rug and board today too.
Yeah.
What the fighting man?
For Real.
Well that's not weird compared to the rest of the weird shit that's in there.
It made great,
but it's whenever there's new weird shit,
it's so,
it's so contrast.
Regular retail giants,
fucking women,
you know,
the Nephilim and like seriously angel wars,
like the angel wars.
I mean to,
I was talking about that a,
that stupid show that I watch all the time.
Um,
uh,
ancient aliens.
Oh yeah.
They're always totally proposing all these nutty Zachary Zachary [inaudible]
where a lot of it,
yeah.
12th planet and all that stuff.
Yeah,
that's all fascinating stuff.
When he's seven.
And what does a 25 100 year elliptical orbit of a planet that comes back into
range?
Actually,
it's 30003000500 years and it's come and it's close.
It's within flying distance right now.
The idea is ridiculous.
I mean,
the idea that they wouldn't have spotted it,
but you know,
I mean,
if something's going to be here in 2012,
believe me folks,
the fucking things going to be giant in the sky and headed our way,
billion miles an hour,
not happening.
Something bigger than,
you know,
earth.
Are you kidding me?
That close.
But you know,
look,
we know for sure that planets collide.
We know galaxies collide.
We know that there was two models of the earth.
There's earth one and earth to heaven and earth.
One didn't have a moon and we got hit by something and knocked them planet
sized.
Right.
You know,
in this chunk of us spun in the sky and became the motion and the ocean actually
is the gap where it used to be.
That's why it's so gigantic.
You've ever heard the hollow moon theory?
The holiday?
Yeah.
That the red moon rings when they land things on it.
That's one of the other reasons why they rang like a bell.
They why they bombed the surface for water.
Hmm.
Was that,
you know,
I guess you the ideal that's artificial.
That's hilarious.
Did you imagine if it was,
you know,
if we found out that it was like,
I can imagine God damn satellite that they put there,
just cover it with dirt.
They're stupid.
They won't know and just watch us.
Totally.
We're a fucking ant farm or the g the biggest reality show ever.
That's where the universe is.
Your and show the fucking light every day or the Kardashians that the universe
aliens sit down in lounges and drink cappuccinos and laughter.
Dicks off at dancing around on television.
Have you seen family,
family jewels that kiss?
Uh,
Gene Simmons,
Gene Simmons and Gene Simmons came to my show so I will not say anything bad
about,
I'm a,
I'm a fan.
I've been a kid having a kiss fan since out of your five years old,
we need to show to like,
yeah.
All right,
so what now this shows obviously fake and I,
they don't really try all father,
his father knows best.
Isn't that bullet cheaper production value.
Yeah it isn't.
That isn't that buggy cause it's like that's weird in between kind of shows that
I keep on thinking that it's supposed to be sold.
I'm not real.
What's real is personality.
When I'm really saying is personally I don't give a shit if the circumstances
real or most times circumstances to fucking boring to watch.
So it's setting something up.
Ultimately.
What's the difference between that and taking a comedian who you watch on stage
who's very funny,
either off the cuff or and written material and going,
let's create a fake family for him based on the characters he created and watch
them react to things that are already set up.
It's even more embarrassing when you write a script for it,
right?
Because there's no variable at all.
I guess it's tricking yourself into reminding yourself to take it like that.
I guess I,
when I watch it,
I just,
it boggles my mind like I have,
I need to try not to like those shows.
I find them boring.
I watched a married to rock the other day.
I watched a celebrity rehab,
which is fascinating to me because no one's famous,
right?
I mean,
Eric Roberts is the most famous one.
Nobody gets rehabbed,
everybody ends up fucked up again.
You know,
the maybe help them a little bit,
you know,
like I'm not,
I'm not a total antedoctal drew guy.
A lot of people say what he does
is on ethical,
that you're not supposed to take people and put them in the public eye and make
them a part of a reality show where they're going through such a serious
situation like that choice.
I understand that,
but what people are saying is it's unethical because the,
the,
the pressure of the cameras and the weirdness of the whole experience,
it's not a,
and sit in the wrong direction.
The wrong direction.
Exactly.
I totally agree.
And I'm not a fan and I have drew,
no,
and I,
and for a long time I was like,
he's,
he's a bigger drug pusher than a lot of the people that he does cause on
Loveline,
on and on and on.
It was just,
what meds are you on?
Have you checked your dosage?
You need to get medicated,
you need to get,
and it was just pharmaceuticals and somehow that makes it okay.
Um,
with a lot of the pharmaceutical drugs been tested on fewer humans than elicit
drugs.
Hm.
With blessed positive effects.
So I mean,
like I said,
I don't do either.
I don't do pharmaceutical drugs either.
Um,
well I think what he's trying to do when he's trying to get people on drugs is
he figures by the time they're calling his show,
they're like on the edge of suicide and he's trying to prevent them from dying.
So what he's trying to do is get them happy for a bit and then hopefully they
can
maybe,
but I think a lot of them just sounded,
you know,
grumpy or wanting to call in and exaggerate their problems in front of everybody
and then,
you know,
and then his,
his,
his end result is let's,
you know,
let's keep this person medicated or whatever,
where it's,
you know,
it's part of the ADHD revolution and the,
and medicating creativity out of people and going,
everything that's different about you.
You know,
instead of exploring it,
you should hide from it and cover it up.
And I,
you know,
there's a big movement in that direction.
I'm not a fan and I think it's a,
it hides behind that to some degree.
Yeah,
I know what you're talking about.
But I've also had friends that have had some severe depression and were suicidal
and then got on some stuff like Zoloft or what have you.
Welbutrin one dude got on and it turned his life around because he all of a
sudden got happier and he moved his life in a more happy direction and he got
more positive about what he wanted to do with his life and his relationship.
I've known people who've got on it and it caught it.
Okay,
understand,
but,
and then he weaned himself off and now he's a very happy guy and very stable and
he was stuck in a bad cycle.
And that does happen to some people.
And I carry be effective in getting you out of a bad cycle.
I totally
great.
I think there are people who drink their way through a problem too and come out
the other side,
arguably with the same result.
But nobody would ever cop to the fact that it was whiskey that got him through.
But you know,
there's tons of country songs about that.
I think it's about,
that's about,
it's a depressant,
but that's the strength of the human spirit I think.
I think a lot of ways he found his way through it.
Other people don't take those exact same drugs and it cranks up the suicidal
reflex that they never had and they ended up killing themselves.
And I think you know,
well it's definitely touch and go.
I mean you really,
I mean that's one of the reasons why they go.
Like I have a friend who's on some stuff right now and he was on some one thing
work and then they put them on some other stuff.
Italian man,
he's a lot nicer now that he's on it.
I like them.
I like them better now that he's on it and he's happier now that he's on it.
He was,
he had some sort of legitimate issue.
Right.
There's just some stuff that I have,
I have problems with and one is that he doesn't exercise and he doesn't eat
healthy and if he did those things first it probably would take care of a lot of
it.
I totally
agree,
Dude.
I cannot,
I cannot go without exercise.
I have real problems.
Yep.
I am not the same person.
I'm a my,
my trigger is way quicker.
I get upset about things that are nonsensical and there's no reason for me to
get even let them into my head and I'll get into a murderous rage about them.
It's just chimpanzee instincts that need to get out.
You know,
with this old hardware,
you've got to work this shit because it builds up.
Yup.
All these hormones and it builds up all this,
you know,
these,
this fight or flight shit is all inside.
You have to express it to me though,
our bodies are designed for 30 years of fucking with Willy Mammoth,
you know?
I mean,
we have to really wrap our heads around that and instead we're sitting at
laptops and don't fuck you to your ex wife on Facebook,
which is not a real expression of it.
And it bottles it up even more.
As a matter of fact,
you expressed that you create those hormones without the genuine expression of
how to get them out.
I,
you know,
I do forms every day.
I do,
you know,
some form of martial arts every single day I do yoga when I get up in the
morning do really every day.
Yeah.
And I,
and for me it's that same mentality.
I always say I'm going to do that.
Then I wound up jerking off and going back to sleep.
Got You.
Do calm foods or something up and take my yoga class,
I'm going to just beat off,
take a nap.
That's another way of unifying your soul with your body and that yoga means
that's the what the word means.
All My,
I agree with you that all martial arts are really sort of a,
it's a like a ice describe.
Taekwondo is a moving meditation,
so when you're totally into it,
when it's over,
it's like all the aggression has been drained out of you and you're at peace and
you're so friendly and happy,
you know,
and from the tips of your fingers to your toes,
your brain is connected all those parts evenly as opposed to,
you know,
like most of us walk around with a dead left arm.
Most of us walk around with a dead right foot because you're sitting around and
you're not,
your attention's going to where you need it.
I use my right hand a lot,
I use,
and if you looked at it objectively,
if you ever just looked at the arm,
you don't use that often you'd think it was dead or palsy because your attention
is so gone.
His arms right now.
See what I mean?
What's fascinating to me when I get guys that are brand new that come into a
martial arts class,
you know when the come to Jujitsu and you see them trying to move their body.
Yeah.
They've never really had to move their body in any strange way.
And here they are 30 looking for some new hobby to exercise with.
So they take a Jujitsu class and they're going through it like they're like
robots,
man.
It's like they can't do it.
We signal does not get to their feet the same way.
And it's so strange and isn't it just as amazing watching them get to the point
where they can,
it doesn't take as long as you think,
but it is.
It's you're like,
oh,
your brain is now attached to that part of your body.
In a way.
It never was.
Every like half of you was on autopilot for most of your life.
I've seen dudes go from being this,
one of the beautiful things about Jujitsu is that a lot of the people that
practice Jujitsu are very smart.
People think of Jujitsu and they think of wrestling and think of like really
strong burly meathead type men.
But most of the guys who do Jujitsu are like,
they're like computer nerds.
They like really smart people who figured out what a crazy thing this is,
that it's all really about leverage and position and technique.
Jews.
Yeah.
It's like you understand Mary Abrasion of the human body and the human body's
moving in a certain direction.
You counter that movement and ply your own pressure.
And I mean it's really like the,
the,
it's really like this incredibly complex game of how to,
you know,
submit a body.
Yep.
You know,
how to stop a body.
Right.
You know,
and people don't understand how much intelligence is behind something like that.
everyone would benefit every single person out there would benefit from some
sort of a Marshall.
I agree.
I think at first of all,
I think tattoos should be taught in schools like either Yang style or something
as it's a way of centering yourself before classes began.
I'm a big fan of,
uh,
do that in business and in schools because your brain,
your body,
you're not fidgeting separately if they're in line to,
what do they do in school?
Do they like have a Tai Chi half hour or something to kind of do like a morning
calisthenics thing,
but it's largely Tai Chi movements that would be such a good move for schools if
schools had some happy moment where everybody met in like an auditorium and
there,
the first thing everybody did yet was say there were thankful to be there and
then go through some [inaudible] thing.
You know,
that's basically what they do in China,
which is why they're eating our lunch.
Um,
but also because they're willing to work for rice.
Okay.
They're willing to work and live in fucking dorms.
Yeah.
That was that place.
They've,
everyone's jumping off the roof,
Brian.
Oh yeah,
John.
Yeah.
Foxconn.
Apparently though,
the percentage of people that commit suicide in that place is a smaller,
relatively to the percentage of people that commit suicide overall.
It's just that this corporation is so huge.
It's got a half a million workers.
Yeah,
right.
It's got around that right.
Wrap your head around a half an hour.
You showing up.
How do you govern 1.2 billion people in one place.
God Damn,
you have Gulf heard off the Internet.
That's what you have to do.
Right.
Cut Off.
Then you start to write and then you started looking at their decisions going,
I,
I'm kind of with you.
Cut off the Internet and,
and,
and make them scared of fire gods.
You know,
you've got to,
nobody's scared of fire gets fucking aliens.
They're flying,
they're flying around the,
and I spent a decent amount of time in China and in Taiwan because I speak
Chinese.
And so I,
I just learned Chinese,
my Kung Fu instructors from Beijing and he's older,
so I,
out of respect for him,
I started learning a little bit of you.
So I sweet.
Yeah.
Kind of Chinese Mandarin.
Do you write it or do I,
yeah,
a decent amount.
I mean,
I'm like a six year old kid.
I can talk really well and really cool.
And Chinese like say,
um,
you are listening to the Joe Rogan experience with Joe Rogan and Brian Red Band.
And you say that in Chinese?
Yeah.
Nations.
I ting to the Joe Rogan experience a gun,
uh,
I guess with Joe Rogan Gun.
Brian.
Yeah.
Wow.
I mean it's,
if you have a new commercial Brian.
Yeah,
totally.
I'm looking forward to it.
How long did it take time in Chinese on the bat?
Um,
I,
uh,
well,
I mean I'm constantly evolving and learning more,
but about two years before I was able to hold down a conversation.
Should go Rosetta stone or did you take classes?
Books and cds mostly.
And then as Rosetta stone work,
it's great.
The new,
the new one is awesome.
I bought Rosetta stone when I first started learning.
It was the original like American system.
That's
where Rosetta stone comes from.
It's the old governmental ambassadorship program.
They started developing,
what do you mean?
That's where it comes from.
That's,
that's the,
the,
the origins of the program.
That's kind of like a department of defense kind of thing where we get
technology from there.
They just figured out the best way to teach a land quickly to ambassadorships
and to,
and for businessmen.
And it was all aimed at that.
And so all like every early Chinese book like,
and I was starting to learn Chinese a little late nineties,
all of them where I work for the American Silk Company,
I am trying to buy this.
Where is the restaurant?
Um,
what time do you get off work?
would you like to come back to my hotel room?
All of it is trying to fuck the locals are fuck the locals.
Wow.
That's funny.
It's true.
And now it's much better now it's moved down and people are learning because
they want to learn.
And most people think Chinese is hard because they have to learn it for
business.
I'm getting transferred over there,
so fuck this is awful.
But if you love anything,
it comes that much quicker.
So yeah.
So for you is just fascinating.
Yeah.
Did you ever do standup in Chinese?
Um,
I,
oh,
I can.
I'm doing the goal is I'm working on doing a special there.
Holy Shit.
Later this year,
later in August,
first of all,
they're going to kill you and shoot you over.
You would tank.
No,
that's what I hear.
They liked me,
but I hear the government probably would,
you know?
No,
I mean I don't get to not talking about some controversial shit I guess.
I mean I try and eat,
stand up.
You've got to keep it clean,
son.
You'd be sure.
It's interesting if you've been there.
Have you been to China?
No.
Never been to China.
I've never been to any Asian country.
I really,
no.
Wow.
I know I need to,
I want to,
I want to go to Tokyo this year for the k one Grand Prix,
but I had been traveling too much.
It go to Taiwan to gray's work in Taiwan is like the Amsterdam of China in the,
you know,
like,
uh,
they're very open society.
It's very Chinese in culturally,
but there,
uh,
but there are demo,
they're democracy and like,
um,
their rules or as loose as are are,
they're actually more open than the United States really.
Um,
but it's,
uh,
it's,
and they're technologically super advanced there.
Uh,
you know,
Taiwan,
yeah.
They've bullet trains and Wifi had cities and shit like that.
[inaudible] has a lot.
They play pool.
I have a,
an addiction to pool do again.
Yeah.
Bad.
And uh,
in Taiwan pool is huge.
It's like,
you know,
the national sport.
Yeah,
I guess so.
I mean,
they pay people to play for the,
the Taiwanese now.
It's a beautiful place.
I've been in a bunch of times and I'm a huge fan.
Um,
but that it's a good precursor to going into China.
When you go there,
people aren't as under the veil as they act and that the communist regime in
China is holding on like white knuckle to this bull of a,
of will of just freedom,
freedom of all sorts.
Like they can't wrap their head around and all they're doing and they're doing
it pretty well is just trying to keep everybody from fracturing and exploding.
That's the whole locking people up.
Blocking dissidence up.
Yeah.
But a lot of the dissidents they do like in the fall and Daca and that kind of
stuff there,
um,
half of us here would go,
I kind of shoot,
we'll,
I should go 0.1,
the Guy Douchey so we'll suck it up.
Do she goes,
sometimes they're,
you know,
hear about the guy and I ran their,
their dissident is our Unabomber to some degree.
Some guy writes a bunch of papers and blow some places up and we lock them up
and you know,
that kind of idea.
Like we don't know the connection to their society and I'm not saying they're
not,
I'm not letting him off the hook at all.
They totally do act in a,
in a horribly authoritative way,
but you get it once you spend time over there,
why and then the,
you know,
and you've got what you get.
You get that.
They just have to because there's too many political yeah.
On occasion they're just,
cause you get to a certain amount of people,
you can't really govern them and he'd know exactly.
That's what I mean.
When there's 1.2 billion people in your country,
you kind of get it.
I'm not actually supposed to be like 50,000 that the map,
but you can only,
I think you can only maintain 14,000 in your consciousness of human beings over
the course of your lifetime.
14th that,
well,
I know you can only keep 150 names.
Yeah.
There's a thing called Dunbar's number's right.
And 50 yeah.
All those are people who have a higher number than others.
That's an average of hard drives.
Pro.
We have bullshit iPhone ones.
Some people have bigger,
you know,
bigger and better ones.
And interestingly enough,
and you deal with this.
Yes.
We're going to say,
oh,
I was just gonna say like speak and spell or web.
Simon says,
remember what assignment,
if you do it like you have this one number and every time it hits that number it
just turns off for me at least and letting it go past it.
You can't go back to that capacity.
Interestingly enough,
like people,
I think it was Jack Nicholson who said,
uh,
he was reading on statistics and you're saying that um,
the average human being in modern society in Western society meets over the
course of their whole life,
9,000 people from deep connections to how are you,
oh,
hi,
I'm Tim.
And have conversation to waving at a bus guy.
9,000 people your whole life.
The average,
even moderate society TV like social,
a celebrity,
like a TV weather man can meet up to 16,000 people a year.
If you're a national celebrity of any level,
you can meet 36,000 people a year and half of those people you actually connect
with.
You spend legit time with them and you know this,
you stand at after a show.
If you do meet and greets or if you meet fans beforehand or whatever,
you're having more of a conversation with them sometimes in that 30 seconds to
two minutes.
Then they've had with anybody in their circle in a while.
Right.
You know,
it's like that guy in Jujitsu class who hasn't used his feet in a long time.
They haven't used their conversational skills with a stranger.
Right.
And express themselves in any deep way to somebody that they're impressed by in
ever.
And so you actually have a deeper connection with and spend more time with and
are connected to more human beings than anybody in the history of the planet has
ever had.
Like from my end priests to Pharaoh's,
they never came in contact with as many people and had direct contact with them.
You're freaking me out than just an average than than than you do.
Yeah.
I've always wondered that because I've run into so many people that I can't
remember.
So unfortunate,
so frustrating.
And it's not that I,
I want and not impersonal like,
man,
I'm just more important.
You broke.
Remember,
it's like
I don't have the room.
There's no room in my brain.
I don't have any room.
Yeah.
And I can't maintain where you are at all times.
Like a tracking device in my,
in my,
and eventually you'll come back if you hang out for a second,
you'll come back.
We'll be there.
Yeah.
And,
and is it your name that's important or that we connect?
You can get a lot of people is their name.
You don't even know my name,
Bro.
You don't even know her name.
Eddie Bravo gotten a thing with this dude recently.
Yeah.
With a guy who's a MMA guy that he's been around forever and he just didn't
remember the dude's name.
And the guy was like,
you don't even know my fucking name,
Bro.
He's like,
dude,
I know you.
Right.
Okay.
You know what I mean?
People I meet,
I don't know your name.
Right,
but I know you.
Is that okay?
Is from the minute we met,
I never knew your name.
Your name never came up.
You'd never came up and said,
hey,
my name is Brian.
Know this dude.
He did know his name.
Oh yes.
I forgot to the people it was,
a lot of people do that though.
They'll,
they'll kind of,
they'll know your name because they know your name.
Right.
So like part of their brain says,
oh,
I don't have to introduce myself.
We know each other.
It's not something you're used to experiencing.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
Meeting,
meeting people after shows.
Is it different from music than it is for comedy?
Totally.
Yeah.
What's the difference?
Um,
let's see.
Oh,
what'd you,
yes.
There's a different girls like singers and comedians.
That's not true.
More girls want to date comedians.
They want to fuck singers,
but they like them both the same.
We serve a different purpose.
Girls after comedy shows want to be your boyfriend,
Brian.
Girls after girls right in the material as we speak.
I want to blow you in a broom closet and really trying to blow you in a broom
closet.
I have to rock shows.
It's selected.
Do slutty shit after rock shows cause it's,
it's a different expression.
You,
you,
it's a different vibe that's coming just to,
you were so special up there alone with that spotlight on you that she wants
that special thing in our mouth.
That dirty bitch.
She wants to be special and make her decide if she wants a good thing.
Johnny,
which is a good thing.
I know buddy man.
That's what I mean.
Like it's girls liking when you call them dirty bitches.
I'm usually meeting with love as long as you're like,
I don't roll that way.
You dirty bitch.
I,
yeah.
Really?
You're hanging out with Ron chicks,
man.
Trust me.
The ones who can appreciate a good you dirty bitch.
Those are the fun ones.
As long as it's not with negative,
it's all no hate in your heart,
right Brian?
Yes.
See I,
yeah.
How's the talking dirty coming along?
Oh,
you're working on that.
Been working on that lately?
How's that coming along?
Yeah.
You know,
I've just been louder with the grunts and sounds,
but I'm going to start.
It's uh,
yeah.
Did you at least put a little bass in it cause you asked,
grabbing the back of that,
it was kind of,
Hey,
what are you in?
Japanese Manga character.
Hey,
what's your come noise?
Is there a drop off or is there an anger at the end of it?
I,
well lately I've been modifying it,
so I'll let let you hate it here.
We'll be done with it.
I'm nice.
I do Ted.
That's not true.
I whispered
earliest the cracking though.
What's the best thing you've ever said while you're busted or not lose your
fucking
mistake.
What the Fuck's wrong?
Take it back.
Shit.
Shacks.
Especially when car side them.
That's why it's such an amazing difference.
The complete different level of consciousness between right before you come and
right after you come,
right before you come,
you're looking at life through a goddamn toilet paper roll.
Yeah.
Like you see almost nothing.
You have the most massive blinders on and then boom,
that's gone right after you come.
And then you're dealing with her breath and her personality and where am I and
what am I doing and how drunk did I get an oh fuck and this is so stupid.
Why is she crying?
Why am I crying?
Really blood is this,
why am I wearing this lipstick?
This is your way of,
these shoes don't fit.
Where's my car?
Right.
Yeah.
See it.
Listen,
man,
if you haven't experienced,
don't knock it,
bro.
These are learning experiences.
If you've never had terrible fucking disastrous sexual mishaps in your,
in your life,
of course,
but not alcohol and do this,
do you ever hit the same level?
No.
I began to go,
I've been completely responsible for it will.
Completely responsible.
No excuses.
You remember it?
Yeah.
That's the problem.
And alcohol is the worst drug,
alcohol and sex together to just like Jesus Christ.
What?
I love alcohol and sex together.
I don't know,
but I'm saying it's like it's not that great.
We know person and yeah,
you know,
but what I'm saying is the idea of the pursuit of alcohol going out and getting
drunk and the pursuit of sex the same time getting to know people.
And you know,
you don't know anybody when you're drunk.
You don't know them.
They don't know you.
Who the fuck is anybody with that pose or get in there,
right?
And then what I'd done,
and that's the amazing thing is it's that you can make a person that way.
There's a reason why your Dick is supposed to be soft when you're drunk,
when you can't get it up because you're drunk.
It's because every fee that doesn't work under that in their body that that,
that that law does not work on me when I'm drunk.
I am harder than I've ever been in my life.
It's like opposite for them.
Everyone Times somebody says,
I'm like,
what?
That's not a real thing.
You know why?
Because you have retard jeans and your,
you're retarded jeans.
They want to be,
you want to propagate the worst situation possible.
Like how drunk is he?
He's really drunk.
How big of a mistake is he making a really big mistake.
Okay.
I want every sperm in that we're going in and you look at her.
This kid will be dumb and ugly.
Yeah,
she stinks.
Her feet.
That's fucking hilarious.
You're in an alley.
This should even be happened.
Let him think he's got the condom on,
but I'm thinking put it on
person.
Blump
take care of me.
Teach me everything.
You're here to make robots.
You're here to make garbage men
to you're here for.
That's hilarious.
Wheat.
That's probably right.
Probably real.
That's the spirit.
That's right.
My Body does not want me producing loads when I'm drunk.
When I'm,
if I'm drunk,
I just,
it's my deck does not want to work.
Does now want and I listened to you chose who you choose as your Dick knows,
you're not thinking straight.
Right.
That's what I mean.
What are you doing?
Stupid.
Where are you don't even know where you are.
No alcohol.
Especially when you're like 20 2021 like you have one of these like in a,
in a glass case break.
Yeah.
Well,
I always have drunk break glass.
I always tell people,
and we used to talk about this amongst my friends when I was a kid,
we used to give each other advice,
like always say,
you know you're going out tonight,
you got to jerk off before you leave the house.
Always.
So we'd have that rule.
Me and my friend showed did Telia we'd always talk about it.
Did you,
did you jerk off?
What are you doing going out?
Don't go out unless you Jurgen off.
I learned that from something about Mary.
Right.
That role.
Do they have that in of America?
Really?
What'd they say?
Say he doesn't,
that's why.
That's where that comes from.
Oh,
that's,
oh that's right.
He didn't know where to come went and she was a great thanks.
It's hair goo on.
It was a great movie.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that it's such an important thing and some guys will talk about it and it's a
big thing.
When you growing up,
what kind of friends do you have?
Do you have the kind of friends that you could talk about jerking off in front
of or do you not have the kind of friends you can talk about jerking off in
front of?
It's very important that you find the right friends,
right?
Because you can have this weird annoying life where you don't really discuss
important,
weird,
you know,
embarrassing shit with each other.
Or you can have the friend that calls you up,
dude,
I just shit my pants again.
I can't have a believes would've fought my card.
I Shit my pants.
If you're around with friends that don't always have to be the hero,
not always the coolest guy in the room.
They know.
I told him to fuck off and then he fucking loved and I know the Troy Pussy,
you know,
if you have the friends that you know,
we'll talk about the embarrassing shit and be honest and real with you,
then you're going to have a fun life.
Then you're going to have a good time laughing till you're crying like a table.
Like I can't fucking right dude.
Some of my funnest moments ever have been talking to a friend after he did
something stupid as fuck and they're calling you up.
I'm an idiot.
Oh my God,
I'm dumb.
And the good part is you have friends who are saying the exact same thing.
Yeah.
Well,
you know that's,
it's a big part of life,
man.
You got,
if there's no sense in like there was a story about this kid that went to Iraq,
comes back,
looks for a hooker,
picks up a hooker.
Santa Monica Boulevard,
gets a bulge from a hooker,
finds out the hookers.
A dude kills him.
Okay?
Dumps the body out of his car.
The cops see him,
dump the body,
high speed,
chase into the desert,
jumps out of his car with a gun suicide by cop.
They kill them.
Plow.
And I'm like,
all because this dude didn't want to admit that a dude blew him.
He would have had one of the best stories ever,
right?
If you're at parties in your dragon,
Mike,
tell us about that fucking dude who blew you.
Okay,
give me another beer.
Totally.
Everybody sit down.
All right,
this is how horny I was.
Totally.
And you know,
it'd be halfway to the story.
I was Kinda like,
God,
is this a dude?
Right?
Yeah.
Fuck,
I don't kick.
Should I come like hi.
Shouldn't
come too late.
Fuck right.
And then I realized it was,
you know,
I mean,
come on man,
that'd be a fantastic story,
dude.
There they PR.
Here's the thing.
That guy died over something that when you go to boot Phuket,
Thailand,
and then they print tee shirts that have,
uh,
a soldier I'm making out with a chick on and,
and uh,
oh,
he's looking down and she's looking down and over his head there's an Arab,
uh,
like a thought bubble that says,
oh,
and he's got a huge Boehner and soda.
She,
and that's the joke.
It's so consistent.
They print tee shirts about it.
And what happens in Thailand to do just get drunk and say,
fuck it all up.
This kid me.
Yeah,
the kid toys there,
which you're the lady boys who look so much like women that don't see it coming,
no pun intended,
that,
uh,
they,
that it just becomes a,
these guys get drunk and then they just pounce on you because the real women
work in the,
in the bars and guys go in and you go,
I want number 52 and you pay to take her out of the bar and you take her
someplace in fucker.
Damn.
Say how many,
what percentage of women and prostitutes in Thailand?
Um,
uh,
I dunno,
I don't know that it's that much bigger than any other country.
I just think they really,
there's a section from there.
Yeah.
They were never conquered by the British or the French,
so they don't have the same sexual mores that we have.
So they're not as hung up about it in that regard.
So it's,
it's not,
you know,
that there's definitely a dark side to it.
No question.
But it's different than we experienced it over here,
like with our sex trade in our kind of bottom feeder mentality with it.
But,
um,
but the interesting thing is that the ones that you that are in the bars,
you see a hot chick in a bar,
uh,
just hanging out on in these like outdoor kind of,
you know,
Jimmy Buffet,
he looking bars where people are buying.
Margarita is getting fucked up,
watching kickboxing.
Then these are all girls.
These girls are all dudes.
Really?
Yeah.
And guys pick them up and they're closing everything else sounds awesome about
Thailand.
I'm like,
Margarita is kickboxing outside.
Greatest Pasa.
I need to go.
Yeah,
it's pretty awesome.
I was blown you.
Hm.
Well,
I mean,
as long as you keep your wits about you,
you have a buddy who keeps his wits about him,
you'll be fine.
What parts of Thailand have you ever been to Bangkok and Paquette?
I want him to go to boating.
There's a place that you can train in tiger.
Tiger.
Muy Thai.
Yeah.
And there's like,
apparently there's a nice resort that's really close by.
I thought about going there for a few days.
It's great.
What does Pooh cat like?
It's,
it's uh,
it's reminds me of Hawaii.
It's like a Hawaiian beach community.
So it's like very modern.
Very,
no,
but it's a steep,
yeah.
That section of it.
Is it safe for kids and shit?
Would you bring little kids over there?
Yes.
In the,
in your,
that resort where you're going to stay.
That's,
I'm pretty sure it's the same place I stayed that um,
yeah,
it's,
it's this total like community.
It's really cool.
Um,
yeah,
there,
there's no worries.
I wouldn't take them to Cambodia,
but they'd get eaten,
right?
No,
it's just the kids in Cambodia.
they do not it.
But in between that,
just for the record,
but in bay shore,
in betweens for Cambodians.
So
you know,
when you look at a map and you see a border and it looks really fucking clean,
you go,
okay,
this is where this country ends.
This is where this country begins.
Okay.
You get to the edge of Thailand,
Cambodia,
that's not the case.
It's very blurry for like 15 miles.
So Cambodia,
their interest there?
No,
Cambodia is nice.
Tile is nice in between the two of them.
The gray area.
Yeah.
There are these cities that have no law governing them either way and they're
really fucked up.
And if you walk through there with a backpack on your reel,
you can fucking feel it,
man.
It's like a Tarantino movie waiting to happen.
You're just like,
this is fucked up.
And hikers go through there all the time there.
It's like American Werewolf in London.
Like just stay on the path and keep walking and you'll be in Cambodia.
Yeah.
Don't go into the saloons.
Don't do any of that.
Just to stay on the fucking road.
God Damn.
That's scary.
Fuck that.
I wrote about that once I wrote a,
I had an idea that I wrote about a gray area in between states.
Yeah.
That it would be like a Las Vegas extreme in every state because our states are
all governed by their own separate rules and yeah.
You know,
remember in Utah used to be that you had to buy alcohol in one section and
mixers in another section.
You had to show your id when you bought them.
And I was,
yeah.
Even in bars,
it was like really tricky.
But you go to Vegas,
you could buy,
you know,
Jack Daniels shots at seven o'clock in the morning out of a slurpee dispenser on
the street and don't give a fuck.
So almost like an extreme version of that in between every state where there was
a mile long area where it was a gray area where you're governed by very simple
laws like no murder,
no theft does it,
everything else do whatever the fuck you got to get help live in one of those
towns.
Will,
he sort of does,
but he lives in a kind of a boring place,
man.
He lives in Bisbee.
It's like he always complains if it's like an artist community,
but no one can.
No one's going to fucking sense of humor,
you know?
Understand.
Hope is a savage drunk.
Yes.
A psychopath's.
Right.
You know,
I'm sure he's laughing about a bunch of shit that these don't beat wearing
douchebag.
Hippies.
Yeah,
but I think near him,
like south of him,
that's where it starts to get a little,
are we in a state that still,
he is seven miles away from the Mexican border,
Bro.
Dude,
you've got his head cut off like that.
He and his girlfriend went out into the river or whatever,
or that mountain to the lake and they crossed the part of the lake that's Mexico
and they fucking got attacked and they cut his head off and mailed it back to
them or whatever.
Like,
fuck man.
Yeah,
but that's very show.
We're better with borders than almost anybody in the world.
We fucking know,
man.
We have a real issue,
you know?
And the issue's not Afghanistan.
It's not Iraq.
The issue is we are connected to a third world country in the middle of one of
the biggest drug wars made was ever known.
Dude,
people don't even realize how big the fucking situation is and how it's fucked.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
The amount of people that have died just this year.
I mean,
it's staggering.
Tens of thousands of people are doing the only growth industry in Mexico was
kidnapping.
Yeah.
It's really scary stuff,
man.
It's right there.
You know,
it's one of the reasons why I didn't want to move to San Diego and college
courses.
Well,
those little kids that are getting caught that are,
you know,
on cell phones,
they have their cell phones to showing torture.
I'll use little kids that are murderers for the drug cartels,
12 years old,
murderers cutting people up and you know,
and video Turkey,
Sierra Leone.
I mean,
ultimately this is stuff that happens everywhere,
by the way.
Not too different from early European stuff.
We just,
you know,
think of ourselves as past it now.
Well,
the problem,
the real true issue with Mexico is that there's no natural gas there and there's
no oil there.
There's not enough natural resources to warrant us taking troops over there and
you know,
stabilizing the area,
I mean,
nobody wants to,
and we don't want to admit it.
He wants to say that.
Yeah.
Nobody wants to say about drug.
Well,
by the way,
the drug money,
we're making money from those drought guaranteed 100% $500 million that the
economy would have collapsed even further than windows.
How frustrating it is because a,
you're a rational person.
How frustrating is it when you talk to regular people,
you know,
your average person,
you have a cocktail party or whatever and you sit down with some guys in
architect and you get into the conversation of,
of where drugs come from and people are so fucking naive and when you tell them
that,
you know,
there's a lot of evidence that the CIA brings drugs in this country,
they'll look at you like you are some fucking nut and you could tell them about
all these different cases where it's been proven true.
You can show,
you know,
reference,
Michael Rupert Books and Megan can reference,
you know,
uh,
all the,
the,
the host,
the case with Barry Seal's in Mena,
Arkansas and all that shit that went down.
How about the CIA plane that crashed recently that had been at Guantanamo Bay on
at least two separate occasions,
crashed in Mexico with four tons of cocaine inside of it.
Right?
Like what the fuck?
It's another form of currency that they use.
It's on the books can currency essentially.
I mean they have to run their own money laundering cause the shit they're doing
is so far down the rabbit hole that they can't,
you can't actually take the cash itself.
The cash itself is too much of a marker.
The numbers on it would trace back to the government too much.
So they literally have,
it would be better to sell it for drugs,
like get drugs and change that money using drugs and then resell that drug for
another currency to hide what's going on and better that the American people
thought our tax dollars were buying cocaine than what we're actually doing with
it.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Well I think it's just,
it's also the,
they know that that's a way to make money and they know that that is going to
exist forever.
And you know,
why not just people need,
absolutely.
There's,
they find a way to justify that they're gonna use it for,
you know,
the,
the Sandinistas and the contracts.
Yeah.
During that extremely,
that was when they were accused of selling crack in,
uh,
the ghetto of course,
in using that money to fund foreign wars.
I mean,
it sounds completely ridiculous,
but what,
what's really crazy is when you have a conversation with someone and you bring
that up,
if you have a conversation with like,
you know,
just some normal person in your neighborhood somehow know that subject comes up,
you're a loon now,
right?
You're a loony do,
You're that crazy guy who believes that CIA is selling drugs.
Right.
But at a certain point,
I think ultimately I've had a lot of those conversations were more and more
people are like,
well yeah,
I mean that happened in the 80s or that happens on occasion or you know,
guys go rogue and do stuff and blah,
blah blah.
But that's not you.
That's not the norm
or whatever.
And like,
no,
this is pretty much the price of doing business and you know,
and it,
when we're literally competing with other giant governments who are doing
exactly the same thing,
we're,
you know,
well,
we're not getting a real accurate sense of the landscape.
You know,
kids aren't being forced to read confessions of an economic hitman in high
school.
You know,
they should be,
you should be forced to watch a bunch of different documentaries on what we do
with money and other countries and how we get their resources and how we,
you know,
give them loans that can ever possibly pay back.
And the whole idea is that we're trying to help them,
but really what we're trying to do is get them attached to debt.
And once we get the mantra of servitude for the Pharaohs did ultimately,
you know,
that was the difference between the slavery of during the pharaohs time was the
idea that you would intentionally indenture yourself for a time.
And then over that time,
like,
uh,
you know,
this illusion of the second,
like how the sex trade runs,
you know,
you'll,
you know what,
we'll give you $20,000,
we get you to the state and you work it off with your vagina and then eventually
you'll be free,
but then you're never free.
Yeah.
You know,
keep moving the goalposts.
Sure.
The Pharaohs did that and that's why everybody got pissed in Split.
Well that's how they do it in the Middle East.
When the building giant buildings and do that and bring these portfolios in from
India and these third world,
China's when,
when I was in Beijing they were,
they were ripping up the WHO tongs in preparation,
which are these essentially these like mud walled ghettos in the center of the
city right in front of the Forbidden City.
In the,
what used to be the emperor's garden are these like low walled houses with nine
families using one to a whole as a toilet and the whole thing it would be like
as if central park was,
was a tent city.
Imagine that and then eventually that tends to be turned into,
you know,
literally just mud crusted bricks that they made themselves in a hole that they
shouldn't.
Yeah.
Over in the middle of their house.
Well there's a drain in,
it drains out into the street.
It's really awful.
So you just hang your ass over the hole and just drop it into a sort of
basically how many fall in there every now and I'm sure can't not
drowning and ship.
What was that movie that recently came out that,
that,
that guy kid fell in?
It was like a kid movie.
Had to jump in there to hide.
No.
What was that movie?
Uh,
jumped in the toilet.
The hotline?
Yeah.
Not a good movie.
[inaudible] [inaudible] all the Indians,
Indian kids,
a slum dog millionaire.
Was that good?
And Lady Hawk actually that you know that Matthew Broderick Rutger Hauer movie
with the Alan Parsons Project.
Weird score.
I never saw that either cause an eighties movie,
but that Matthew Broderick is his plays,
this character fleet,
the mouse who's a contortionist and he's a thief and he escapes from the
dungeons of Aquila,
which nobody has ever escaped war by basically cracking his bones and sliding
his way through.
Oh Wow.
It's amazing.
But through this sewer,
a dude named Lee Marie,
that was a,
he's a bank heist guy from England who was trying to get out of his chair,
his cage by starving himself so small that he could slip through the bars.
Like he was starving himself to try to get skinny enough to slip through his
cage.
Well as you would do after awhile.
Yeah.
But that's retarded.
You're not going to do,
don't you think the bars are too small for you to do that?
Well,
what they do is they measure
you.
They make sure your skull and your hips can't get through.
Yeah.
Come on man.
You ain't getting through them.
Yeah,
right.
That's right.
But uh,
yeah.
Desperate man.
Where were we anyways?
Yeah,
the,
we really went like sideways.
I blame the Lady Hawk reference and that was,
I really,
totally weird.
But,
um,
and who tongs in China,
basically to live in Beijing,
to live in the big city,
you had to have,
you have to have a card that says you live there.
It's like as if New York said,
look,
there's too many fucking people in New York.
Yes.
Everybody wants to live here.
But since we don't charge for rent anymore,
it's a communist society.
We got to have a hierarchy of some sort.
Either have to have lived here a long time or you got to give something up,
take the lid off.
They don't pay any rent at all.
No.
Um,
well you,
you can,
uh,
outsiders do and there's a,
it's a weird system,
but essentially that you can get a better place by paying,
but essentially your basic level stuff is there.
So what they would do is they would go to these little towns,
which were a piece of shit towns that they were having the communist party was
having to maintain.
I have to run water out to these dipshit towns that have nothing to offer.
They're just out there and they had to provide for them.
Then they'd go into the town,
they go,
alright,
everybody out.
We're taking all the wiring back in the plumbing back and we're taking all the
concrete and everything.
We're going to pulverize this whole city.
And this whole town is going to live in a high rise in Beijing that you're going
to build yourself.
So we're going to give you the construction for two years.
The best workers here are going to go into the city.
You're going to work on this tower.
And then by the time the towers finished,
everybody moves into it and we'll just pulverize the whole city.
It's as if we went to Fairfield,
California or some small town where the industry has left.
So what's the hook that there is none other than you don't get to have your old
town in your nice little village.
So they actually do build this place and they actually do live in.
Yep.
Okay.
So it's not the same as like what's happening,
you know,
but no,
but the,
but yeah,
no,
they actually pay off eventually,
but,
but that's the good version of it or whatever.
In Dubai,
they just,
you know,
in Dubai it's interesting because they stopped paying and the fucking workers
just started walking home.
It just all pack their shit and started walking to the edge of town.
That whole place is so crazy that we've ever been there.
So yeah.
Yeah,
it's such a high level and then it just kind of all came crashing down based on
it.
It's a resource based economy and limited resource based economy and you can't
eventually that's going to go dry no matter if it's now or 50 years from now.
You're banking your whole worth on oil.
These fuckers are going to be hocking rugs like they were in the fifties sooner
than they know it and it's going to be a creepy period for them.
Well,
they also have debtor's prisons,
so you can't be,
you can't be in debt,
you can't just go bankrupt over there.
They lock you up in jail.
Right.
So a lot of people,
they parked their Mercedes at the airport,
got on a flight and just left everything.
But hopefully like,
I don't want to be in jail.
Fuck you and your country take care.
Exactly what people were living there.
Like Michael Jackson was living there.
Right.
I mean,
it got to be this,
you know,
really the idea of this enchanted paradise place where millionaires when just
sounds like nuts and sounds like,
it sounds like the Las Vegas run by southern Baptists.
The whole thing was really fascinated.
Religious police.
Like I got them called on me during my show.
Ooh,
during your show in Dubai.
Yeah,
I was,
I was doing a show with Jon Lovitz of all people,
I guess.
And,
um,
he,
I was,
I did the verse 45,
he did the second 45 and I introduced him in between show,
you know,
our shows and I come out in this,
uh,
and um,
so I'm up on stage and um,
I had gone up to the top of the Burj Khalifa,
the tower,
the tallest building in the world.
I've now been in four of the tallest structures in the school,
whatever,
blah,
blah.
I feel like it's pretty,
it's actually,
you know what it looks like it's the same view.
You get an a landing airplane,
you know when you're flying into lax and you're over that what would be Pasadena
and all that shit.
You're that high in the air.
That's what it looks like.
I would just start shitting and pissing him off.
He's like pass out,
but it's all dirt.
It's terrible.
And I,
I even said like,
I think it's great you guys built a tower that high because that's dirt looks
its best from about 3000 feet.
You know what I mean?
Dirt up close sucks,
but all this dirt so great to see it.
Cause there's no,
they implant any fucking trees.
It's all construction.
It looks like shit.
So,
and they don't even like the biggest observation.
Dick doesn't even face the water,
the Caspian Sea cause they wanted to impress people with what the city looks
like.
So they put the observation deck on the inside will,
the city hasn't been built yet.
So bullshit.
Anyway,
so I go up to the top of it.
It was originally called the Burj Dubai based on the city,
the shake Khalifa,
the,
the president of the UAE gave them $10 billion to finish the tower.
$10 billion to finish it because it didn't look like he was gonna.
And so on opening day they decided,
you know what,
fuck this,
we're going to name it Burj Khalifa after him,
like this impulse thing.
But you go up in it.
And I was one of the first 200 people to go up in it,
you know,
and um,
and I go up and the gift shop all has shit that says Burj Dubai on it.
And it's the same bullshit gift shop crap you'd find at the Sears tower or in
Disneyland.
It's fucking golf shirts and,
and pocket knives and bottle openers.
And they all have Burj Dubai paperweights where there's water in it and you can
shake it comes on their little towers,
no snake sandstorm.
Maybe
it's stupid like eh,
but it all still said Burj Dubai on it.
I'm like,
this motherfucker gives you $10 billion and you can't replace the bullshit
printed shirts in 24 hours.
What did you say this?
Yes.
So I basically what I said on stage was it's pretty rude to monsieur Khalifa.
I think that you,
you know,
you did this or whatever because I'm not paying for my hotel room.
But when I call room service,
they say,
they say yes,
Mr. Sparks.
They don't say the guy who was in the room before me,
you know?
And,
and I was actually trying to say something deferential,
respectful to the guy,
you know.
Well,
it was the fact that I said Monsieur Khalifa instead of shake Khalifa that drove
this one guy crazy and he stood up in the back like eight tables back and people
were laughing.
So I didn't see this happen.
He was back in the dark
and he storms out of the fucking place.
Whoa.
I walk off stage to finish my set.
It was great set.
Actually.
I had a great time and it was,
he's like $40,000 tables,
you know,
Evers round tables in the front full of shakes and these guys I can and women in
their hijabs and Burkas and the whole deal.
And then there are business partners from the west,
so it's really weird.
So I go off stage and promoters there and he goes,
uh,
yeah.
Uh,
you said something that offended one of the shakes who was here and so he called
the CID,
the religious police,
and they're here and they're going to take you into custody.
We'll try to,
yeah,
this is fucked.
That,
wow.
We'll try and mitigate it as much as we can.
But the fine could be as much as $25,000 and three days in jail.
And,
but we'll try and talk them down and it might not be a big deal because we're
not even sure what he was upset about yet.
And we'll try to talk to them about it.
But can you go out,
take this out,
can you go out and introduce John?
Fuck and then come back and we'll deal with it.
So I walk out on stage and I,
I go up on stage and I introduced John and as I'm on there,
as I'm onstage introducing them,
I see them come down the aisle,
I see the religious police,
these,
uh,
there are three of them in these white shirts with their little belts across
their chest and a little,
you know,
stick holsters and stuff.
And they're walking down the aisle towards backstage and they go backstage and I
introduced John and instead of going backstage,
I walk straight off the stage and walk right out to the lobby where they had a
table set up for me to sell shit and sign things.
Whereas where I had intended to go in the first place,
but I walked,
I just,
instead of going backstage and I went straight out front,
I'm like,
they'll find me out there.
They're gonna find me,
they gonna find me,
but I'm going to go out there and do that shit first and let them stew.
You have to sell your merge.
Yeah.
Right.
So I go,
so I go outside and I'm taking in a bunch of pictures and shit up there and
totally and DVDs and,
and it took pictures and blah blah.
And I had a bunch of people come out because John is Jewish,
I'm not Jewish.
And they definitely have issues with Jews there.
So a lot of them came,
saw me and didn't stick around towards the Jew.
Right.
Assholes.
Anyway,
so they come out,
I'm,
and these guys are back there for 10 fucking minutes before they realize he's
not coming back.
Right.
And so they could turn around and come out to the office.
And right when they walk out,
I'm getting a picture with a shake and his wife like this,
like,
like you were in fucking Wisconsin arm around both of them.
Big stupid grin there,
smiling.
He's got his fucking classic sunglasses,
White Shawl.
The whole deal is white burqa.
You can't even see your fucking,
this is it.
And I'm just a big smiley picture.
I'm assuming she's smiling and um,
and they,
they come out and they go,
well,
if he hadn't said anything offensive,
these people would be,
they would not take a picture with him.
This shaker would a dealer and his wife would not be taking pictures if he said
anything would have saying they'd saw it.
They watch.
So they basically said he's not,
he didn't offend anybody because if he did,
the would be mad too.
And so they went to the,
uh,
the shake who was standing by the doorway.
I didn't know who it was,
but apparently he was standing.
He said they walked over with their arms crossed.
What did he say?
What was the big and he goes,
well it wasn't what he said.
I was just thought that other people might get defendant.
He started backtracking on what he said.
Oh.
So they stuck around and watched John Show for about 10 minutes to make sure he
wasn't doing anything untoward.
And I think they ended up finding him $25,000 fine.
John 25,000 mentioning his Judaism too much.
Fuck that.
Yeah.
Don't ever go there.
Here's the other.
Yeah Dude.
Like God dude.
So cause it wasn't anything else.
I mean he does this thing.
Bob Saget is gay.
This song he does,
which like might've been it.
Cause you're mentioning homosexuality is worse than mentioning Judaism there.
I think almost two.
They conflate the two.
But it's psycho.
I mean it's crazy behavior.
Imagine if Fred Phelps,
his family ran Vegas.
Who's Fred Phelps?
The Westboro baptist.
Yeah.
God hates fags out of Oregon.
I was like,
imagine if they ran Vegas.
Oh my God.
Every time you were,
you were having a great time in Vegas.
You had to like kind of stop and make sure that nobody went and told Fred Phelps
is fans,
you have reservations go in there and performing there or do we like,
oh,
it'll be okay.
I not really,
I felt okay about what I was going to say and I knew that like that was an
issue,
but I didn't think I was going through my act going is there anything that
they're going to come Hutch,
did you swear?
Do you swear at all?
Yeah.
This is a training problem.
No,
they didn't.
They weren't bothered by sexual stuff.
You love to talk about sexual stuff.
Yeah.
Really?
How much soup?
B level,
I mean not by be.
You talked about popping pussies and stuff and I known I would.
You wouldn't go there.
What is,
what is popping?
Posing?
That's what you snap it.
What do you do with your fingers?
No,
you just pop it.
How do you do that?
Just pop it.
What the fuck does,
I don't know what that means.
The songs about it,
you know,
two live crew pop that pussy.
I think they just don't find that on Youtube.
Whatever you do.
I see the little fingers moving.
Yeah.
Cut The shit young man.
So I,
yeah,
I just,
I was more interested in just the experience of going there.
Like this should be really fucking good.
Yeah.
We did the UFC and Abu Dhabi,
it's a job is different.
It's interesting.
There's a different tone between that and Dubai.
I refuse to fly into Dubai for that reason.
I didn't want to fly in there dude.
And plus I knew how they,
what they did with their labor,
how they got these people from third world countries.
They promised them an extreme amount of money and then when they get through the
take their passports away and give them a fraction of their money.
Right.
They live in squalor conditions.
Like I don't want to be connected.
Totally.
Yeah.
I don't want to feel that.
Well at this point it was already kind of on its downward arc and I was just
curious as shit to see like where everything,
cause it was literally like cranes.
It was something stupid.
Like 22% of the worlds' cranes.
We're in Dubai.
And as they were showing gains,
yeah,
he goes cranes in the use to build the world's tallest building.
Like what the fuck dude,
man.
Yeah.
Stupid.
So,
and by the way,
the Burj Khalifa,
the tallest building in the world,
they decided they want the world's biggest mall as well.
So they bailed it at the base.
Okay.
The biggest building has the biggest mall in the world.
And they decided to use bigger than the mall of America.
Yes.
They took,
by the way,
the way they did it was they proud,
but people,
they decided to take the design for the mall of America and duplicate it.
So they basically in double it,
that's what they did.
Those cunts.
Exactly.
And you know what?
It isn't shit.
Mall of America is basically round.
It is obvious.
So there are these two giant balls at the base of the Burj Khalifa.
It is the biggest,
dumbest Phallus you have ever seen in your life.
It's so fucking obvious to this.
The most attractive thing you said all night.
I want to go to that mall right now.
Right.
Me Too.
By the way,
I'm a small way.
You go into the top is through the mall.
You start in one of the balls and go through this writing.
How is their food court?
Is it good?
It's ridiculous.
Cause they're good.
They have cinnamon.
No,
it's just in such,
in a bond.
Not Good.
Well I mean they have,
they better have Starbucks and cinnamon.
I,
yeah,
well I guess,
technically they do have Starbucks.
I don't,
I don't know remember seeing it,
but they had like,
they had candied dates with caramelized almonds inside them,
wrapped in like a leaf of vanilla frosting or something like,
and box,
just rows and rows.
Cause that's,
you know,
and they were fucking amazing.
I brought boxes of 'em back to everybody.
That was the thing.
Middle East is quite a trip,
man.
Um,
one thing I wanted to get into with you before we wrap this thing up,
early five 30,
Geez,
I've read,
I've,
I've seen a lot of shit.
One thing that I saw that really brought my,
uh,
brought my attention to you was you got interviewed at the airport about nine
11.
And it was,
uh,
it was pretty fascinating because,
you know,
there's two groups of people usually that,
um,
you know,
when it comes to nine 11,
there's these people that say,
well,
you know,
obviously,
uh,
the government makes mistakes,
but you know,
this was a,
this was,
we were attacked by,
you know,
some,
a terrorist organization.
There's a reason why we're in these places over overseas and we're there to make
sure that we can have freedom here.
And then there's another,
there's another group of people that think,
hey,
something happened here.
This is an inside job.
There's a lot of people,
there's a lot of,
you know,
there's a lot of facts that don't jive.
There's a lot of information that doesn't job,
but a lot of those people are crazy.
Yes.
And a lot of those,
those,
you know,
nine 11 truther is like you listen to them and there's,
you know the expression,
the term confirmation bias where you're looking for information that's going to
confirm your suspicions instead of just be composed.
Religion is based on that.
Yeah.
Nine 11 is the biggest religion thing for that.
It's a,
it's,
it's a crazy thing.
Sure one.
But one thing that's been to me proven that even,
I don't know what happened on nine 11 I don't know if there was government
complicity.
I don't know.
I don't know if you know the,
the,
the statements of,
you know,
Wolfsburg and Rumsfeld and Dick Cheney,
I don't know how many of those are accurate and how many of those we need a new
Pearl Harbor.
And you know,
I don't know how much of that is real,
but I do know that if they did do it,
they could pull it off because I'm paying attention to the way people were
reacting to some people that refuse to think that it's possible that the
government would ever be involved in anything shady at all.
There's a giant group of,
you know,
love or leave it,
there's a giant gods,
guns and government group in this country.
Yeah.
You could pull off,
almost everything can count on it.
You can,
you can,
you can literally bank on their how they're going to read stuff.
Yes,
exactly.
The Sarah Pailin book signing people,
you know,
they're waiting in line,
you could trick them with fucking anything.
Three Card Monte,
you know,
you can get,
and if you scare them,
it's even better because that fear part of their brain will trigger and they
will,
everything will dovetail bottleneck through that air.
Next thing you know,
they're drinking beer,
watching fucking red dawn screaming wolverine right there.
Ready?
Yep.
What do you,
what do you think happened
on nine 11?
What is your feeling?
I think,
well,
um,
I'm a big believer in that.
Uh,
you know,
uh,
most of the time the official story is horse shit,
especially on big scale,
things like that.
I think,
um,
there's a good combination of Cya and intentional,
uh,
push that mixed at the right time.
And again,
Robert Anton Wilson said,
yeah,
there's uh,
um,
there are groups that run the world.
There's not more,
they're not just one group that runs the whole world.
There's several that are trying all the time and they fuck up like anybody else.
They have shit sons who do,
don't do their job right and ruin the family fortune for a decade and have to
come back.
So I don't believe in this perfect world order Bohemian Grove Bilderberg group
thing where they get everything they want and there's nothing we can do and
blah,
blah.
You know,
they're like,
that's where I buried from the Alex Jones kind of.
They're a perfect monster.
It doesn't work that way.
Everybody is fallible and I think in a lot of times they do know in the
Reichstag fire and those kinds of things,
false flag operations work very well.
Building one yourself is very difficult letting one happen when you know it's
already coming by looking the other way,
like some people argue with Pearl Harbor was we knew it was coming,
but we also knew that was the impetus to get in there.
And we had a bunch of,
you know,
um,
well we pulled out American warships.
Yeah.
We pulled out warships because we knew that it was going to be hit.
I mean the actual,
there was a history channel documentary that have aired recently that have
gotten as far as saying that we were aware of the attack and allowing it to
happen so that we'd be brought in the World War II.
Much like I think,
um,
comedy plus,
you know,
tragedy will or time plus tragedy equals comedy.
You know,
people can make comedy out of something and as long as it's far enough in the
distance,
I think a lot of us can also accept things the further there in the distance we
can war two or Gulf of Tonkin.
Exactly.
Once you go,
oh yeah,
well sure.
There was the right type of higher they the Gulf of Tonkin incident.
Yeah.
Pearl Harbor probably had some better.
We solicited but this just happened and we want to believe in our own.
We want to believe that the different time unfulfillable because we're,
this is,
those are,
those people are idiots.
We,
on the other hand,
I couldn't get food like that.
And I think,
um,
I think like,
like the,
like the recession,
I think the recession was something that could happen at any time because our
financial system in this country is a house of cards as it is in most countries
around the world.
It's based on what the Chinese called funk p,
which means fart air.
It's just,
it's,
it's smells and you know,
it's there,
but it has no substance at all.
It would not say you can't,
you know,
fart errors there,
but you can't rest or the economy.
Yeah.
But you can't rest your cup on it as it described the economy that way.
That's amazing.
And so the,
um,
we,
we know that at any given time you could,
you could crush this.
You could,
you could,
you could bring me down because it's not even based on gold anymore.
So even that,
even,
even money based on gold is a resource that people have to agree has worth.
Right.
Which is even,
I think,
ridiculous.
Less flexible than creativity.
Yeah.
You know,
I know what you're worth as a human being.
I can't eat gold once I need it.
But I know you guys can figure out how to farm.
Well,
the really crazy thing about gold is the Zechariah Hitch and definition of why
we are tell us,
cause we were monkey.
We were told that we
are genetically programmed to dig it up.
Yeah.
Well that's along with diamonds and other shit cold.
No.
The reason we'd go for gold is he,
he wrote this in the 12th planet,
his book that came out in the 1970s.
Yeah.
That the ancient Sumerians when they were uh,
were being raised by the Annunaki,
the ideas of the Annunaki came from this other planet,
these aliens,
and they interdicted their DNA into human DNA to teach them to mined for gold.
And the reason why they want him to mine for gold as they needed to suspend gold
particles in their atmosphere to protect themselves because they,
in their quest for technology,
much like us,
they destroyed their environment.
Right.
And that,
that and that they needed it puffed around here temporarily,
like an and part of a particular farm,
which that's conductivity makes sense.
Yeah.
Well they didn't figure that out until like 2000.
It was like they had some sort of a symposium on climate change and they were
trying to figure out ways to protect us if we lost,
you know,
a good percentage percentage of our environment.
And one of the ways was to suspend gold dust or reflective particles in the
atmosphere to reflect.
The other thing is paint your fucking roof white.
If every,
if every house in America had a white roof instead of a black roof,
it would reflect as much light as the,
uh,
as the polar ice caps would.
And what would that do for us?
It would,
it would reflect the heat.
I mean that's really,
ultimately the ice does,
it doesn't specifically cool the planet in that regard.
It reflects the light back instead of absorbing it and the absorptive he wants,
the ice is gone.
The darkness of the rocket stuff pulls the,
the heat in,
whereas the sunlight reflects it back.
Um,
you know,
the white reflects it back.
So one of the big,
like a green tech things that they're trying to push is white roofs or light
colored roofs.
Huh.
But what about solar?
Well,
solar absorbs but and uses it for another source.
But in so far as rooftops,
you know,
that aren't being used for that,
like sand does the same thing.
It's why you would have to make a choice.
Yeah.
Well not necessarily you environment or free electric.
You get as much as you'd want and then you did every other portion would be
white.
Eventually we will have reflective solar panels will have inter like the light
bounces off the black silicone and,
and then go,
which is a relatively new molecule that we're using.
Uh,
well I say we,
but you know,
human beings will be used,
stand up comics totally come up with new films.
The inside of it will be,
we'll bounce the white back into it and then it'll look white to the outside
viewer.
But certain UV we'll get through the first one to get off the grid.
I really need to do it.
It's one of the reasons why I moved to Colorado for a bit to,
you know,
get the grid dude,
you could totally do it here.
You get enough sunlight,
your appearance.
Yeah,
yeah.
Work like a charm.
But,
but in so far as,
uh,
you know,
the,
the concept of ever getting back to kind of nine,
11 and the idea of was it,
um,
you know,
manufactured or was it,
what,
we're attacked or whatever.
I think there's,
there's a case for both at the same time they operate that there are people in
the government who saw opportunity in letting one slide through and maybe they
didn't realize how big it would be.
Maybe they didn't realize that it would be as big as nine 11,
that it would be maybe another.
Yeah.
But if they were going to let plain slamming the idea,
that's what I mean is NATO stood down and let this happen.
The,
they had been,
they had been warned about people hijacking planes,
the slamming of the buildings in advanced.
I agree.
But maybe they thought they could.
Uh,
maybe again,
maybe to control,
be complicit.
How many people have to be complicit is just a small number and everyone else
just follows orders.
It's a small number and everybody else has to think they're falling to write
orders and there's not compartmentalize.
It's like the arguments against chem trails.
If you look at chem trails and you go,
okay,
maybe here's what,
here's what you have to do.
Here's your tough decision.
You're in government.
Somebody comes to you and goes,
look,
there's unequivocable signs.
We're fucking up the atmosphere and if we don't start having more reflective
clouds in the sky,
we're dead,
especially over big cities.
So what we're going to start doing is we're going to start seeding the clouds
with barium and aluminum and we're going to bring back the cloud cover over our
major cities.
So we bounced back some of the pollution and we bounced back the light the other
direction,
and we have to do this.
Otherwise 40% of the American populace will die.
Why not tell people about this?
Because by doing it,
12% are going to die.
Barium and aluminum will kill a certain number of the weak among us.
Let's say this is a bad,
so you believe that all those things in the sky,
those lines are all,
no,
I'm just saying I'm using a sentence.
Do you believe that though?
What do you believe?
Well that's the thing is I,
I do think there's,
whether manipulation going on and people,
this is definitely what I'm going to be like been more,
it's been documented.
It is,
you know,
in,
in Georgia if there's certain forms you have to fill out,
you know,
and yeah,
I forget what the exact subject is,
but it's a government form and one of the things has to deal with weather
manipulation.
So it's a standard.
Totally.
I mean we have,
we've already shown that it can be done totally.
In the 70s the government decided we were going to be on the cutting edge of it
in American government decided we were going to be on the cutting edge of it.
And by the way,
at that same moment,
the Chinese went,
Oh yes,
too.
And just immediately started leapfrogging ahead of us in the technology.
But the point is,
the nine 11 part comes in,
you've got,
you've got these planes flying over,
you got soldiers going up every day and they know they're dropping Berryman
aluminum into the atmosphere and they know it's a bit of a secret thing and they
know it's for the betterment of man.
[inaudible]
information though.
How do you know,
I'm just,
I'm using these as examples,
whether it's a true ab is amazing.
Maybe as a maybe theory.
Yeah.
This is where the nine 11 part kind of that,
where it kind of,
there's parody in,
in the argument whether or not it was an external or an internal threat or who
needed to stand down,
who needed to be,
um,
on the game,
in the game and outside the game.
Okay.
So you've got every day you've got soldiers,
you come up to him and go,
look,
we have this new plan.
It's necessary to save.
Lots of lives are going to fix the atmosphere.
It's when you guys are on the prowl,
the soldiers this,
well,
no,
you've got this front line thing.
Well cause you're not dumping shit behind your plane.
You're not going to do it everyday without some sort of an answer.
So they're going to go to you,
look,
this is what we're doing and you're going to notice the difference everyday
you're going to drive home from your job at the base and you're gonna look up,
there's gonna be cloud cover that wasn't there before and they're,
and you're a part of that mission.
It's very important part of that mission.
And you guys are how,
how has this not yet out though?
Don't you think this would get out though?
You think there'd be some dude that would be,
his fucking voice would be altered on some television show.
I think there are guys like me that what I was doing was going to save the
environment,
but I think it'd be,
well that's,
I think they pick their guys very well.
Yeah.
And you know,
so how often do you think this is happening?
That they're spraying shit in the,
in the sky?
Why?
I mean if you look at the criss cross patterns in the air over Los Angeles meet
three times a week.
Do you know though that that's been proven that turbine engines interact rate
costume in the APP?
I'm not even arguing.
No,
no,
no.
I'm not arguing whether or not to actually treat clouds.
I mean it actually the moisture and when it gets spun [inaudible] in chemtrails
down is not true,
but it's dependent scientifically dependent on the amount of moisture that's in
the air.
I think that you prove that moisture and make it do certain things and that's
what whether manipulation,
right?
But these planes,
I'm not even numb.
Not Assuming whether it's valid or not.
Leaving these trails is so substantial that you're,
you're,
you're including commercial Aircrafts and I'm knocking around because you would
never criss cross commercial aircraft in the air and the atmosphere,
you would never create perpendicular lines in the same atmospheric level with
commercial planes.
And by the way,
near cities they don't fly at that height.
They,
the,
the trails that you're seeing that are,
that are effectively what would be called chem trails are,
are higher than planes fly when they enter Los Angeles atmosphere to land or
take off and they do not reach those outs.
Dudes until they are well outside that area when you sitting criss cross.
Okay.
And a checkerboard pattern flight patterns of you really studied this,
you would never happened ever criss cross planes in the air at that Alto.
Why don't you,
when people are coming from,
do you all get the same way?
No,
they all bank around.
They go in circular format like this but they and and on two levels and that's
why you have east and West or north and south landing strips.
That's why you circled people around in a specific pattern trough seems to be
something that should be discussed.
Like why isn't that in Bourbon?
Lax Burbank has to go that way.
It can circle around that much.
It's not that far away.
You know that,
that those Burbank airports.
Yeah.
And then you have John Wayne and the Orange County's coming up this degree.
There's only so much so that they get in and Gulf streams like a road and they
have and they have uh,
they have like what would be like sort of Col-de-sac he looking turns that the
planes go through and you've been in them,
you've been in holding patterns that go around and they're circular and they go
back around to specific landing strip but they never,
criss cross is never a point where the bang really do a real audit of the actual
patterns over La.
This is a look at them.
Tough.
Yeah,
but you can't just say that.
I think how,
I mean on what the online you can actually see the airplane.
Yeah.
But blind patterns,
but you can see where they're supposed to go.
Exactly where they do go,
where they do go.
What about cargo planes and a bunch of other different kinds of things as well.
They all use the same path point.
Technically they should.
Yeah,
because you don't,
you would never,
you would never have a plain criss cross.
Another.
The point is I'm not arguing for or against chem trails.
I'm using it as an example.
Okay.
I'm using this example.
Let's say that based on a hypothesis,
you have soldiers who are told every day you're doing something to help the
environment and you're flying up every day and you're dropping a this barium in
aluminum into the atmosphere because this helps us create cloud cover and this
is the whole point.
And you go,
okay,
good.
All right,
as a soldier I'm onboard.
That's great.
And then one day somebody switches the canisters doesn't tell you,
didn't tell anybody else and you dump
pesticide or a poison or lithium on the public lithium and you don't and you
don't,
I'm not saying this happens,
I'm just saying that's where the conspiracy doesn't have to involve you at all.
You will do exactly what you're told because you've been doing something that
you perceive as good,
like every plane that went north to do a war game to practice against Russia as
if it was necessary.
None of those guys were bad guys.
They were just following the order that was given them and that eventually that
gets to a smaller and smaller portion of the group that are on a need to know
basis.
And they just kind of offer orders and we're going,
this is the day we're going to do a big NATO exercise.
Okay,
what's,
how's this different from any other day?
We do a big NATO exercise.
Well and this one other shit is happening,
but you're not privy to that point.
You're still a good guy.
That's why there's so many good guys can be involved in something nefarious
without them actually being involved in it.
You know,
specifically they don't have any inclination or any information.
And that's where people's fears,
I think of chem trails come from is the idea,
you know,
whether it's true or not is that they're afraid someday.
Dick Cheney and his buddies have CECI.
Yeah,
we'll decide to switch
barrels.
You know,
and people think that this is completely outside the realm of possibility and
absolutely Wacko Nis,
and you're talking crazy.
But operation Northwoods is the one thing that always rings in my head.
And if you're not aware of it,
go read about it online because it was a,
it was a document that was drafted by the Joint Chiefs of staff signed by the
Joint Chiefs of Staff.
So they were down with this proposal and it was vetoed ultimately,
and it was in 1962 and the idea was that they were going to attack American
civilians,
they were going to attack Guantanamo Bay,
they were going to blow up jetliners and saving their way to Cuba and they were
going to blame it on Cuba and we were going to go to war with Cuba.
Get this.
Exactly.
It's amazing
guys.
A lot of those guys,
by the way,
still work in the military.
Absolutely.
By the way,
risen in rank since
then and by the way were never arrested.
And by the way,
everything where you don't have a massive fucking calling of all these corrupt
people in government,
everything evolves include including corruption and if corruption existed in the
18 hundreds it's still around today and if it existed in 1962 and no one went to
jail for it,
well words,
where's the track?
The lineage.
Zach who hired who?
So what does people hired the next generation and they train them and then it's
all the same thing.
Then
the chem trails argument is,
or what?
I'm basically using it as an example of how you could create a nine 11 kind of
circumstance.
Almost any level.
Just good people all and they don't even know.
I don't even aren't even aware of it because they're doing something that they
think is helping.
You know what I mean?
Let's say,
I don't
know if I agree with you about the chem trails thing.
I think I need to look into it and find out what the deal is with the weather
patterns and I just don't know how it could be so prevalent.
It just seems silly to me.
It seems like you would have too much fluid.
You'd have too many,
you know,
it'd be too obvious to many people would be talking about it to me again,
I have no,
I wouldn't do it during the day.
why would they?
Why wouldn't they do it?
And they'll do it at night.
While the idea is,
hey,
maybe clouds only lasts a certain amount of time or you need to do it during
sunlight hours.
But the point is the way I agree with you that it's possible that it could
happen and I have no dog in that race all I'm just,
I was using
it as a pure example of where you could get soldiers as a,
as a direct example to do exactly what they're told in a positive sense on a
secret level where they know they shouldn't tell anybody because they know sort
of consequentially that they're doing something good but not everybody would get
it.
And it's a level of secret that's actually important.
And then flip the game where it could be something very negative.
Do you ever feel frustrated that when you talk about any of these weird subjects
that you get labeled as like a nut,
you get labeled as like a loose thinker,
a Wacko.
Cause if you start talking about like tower seven,
what happened with towers having,
right,
you're a,
you're a loon man,
you get boxed into this category of conspiracy theorist,
which automatically makes it very easy to dismiss you.
But I also think that as a comedian,
I think it's our job to not give a shit what other people think and say stuff
that other people don't feel the freedom to say whether or not we get rid of and
laughed at or with is almost immaterial.
And I think we owe it to ourselves as comedians specifically is the philosophy
that goes with comedy to take,
uh,
you know,
to cut angles as you'd say in Jujitsu to go,
instead of taking a force directly on,
let me look at it from this angle,
this angle,
this angle and this angle.
Whereas other people only have the,
they'll only look at the tiger by its teeth and its nose.
And know that it's scary and know that they don't want to fuck with it.
I think one thing that comics or any public speaker that you know has an
interesting point of view does is they offer a different path for the person to
start thinking.
Right?
Then other people will listen to you and say,
you know what?
This house parks guys making a lot of fucking sense.
You know,
like maybe I'm not a hundred percent agreeing with him,
but I see that this guy has really thought this out.
Maybe I should consider his his ideas and maybe it's not even about this.
Maybe,
maybe you're not looking at nine 11 you couldn't give a rat's ass whether it was
fake or real,
whether it was staged or an actual attack and it has no real bearing on your
life personally.
But you might come in touch with a situation in your own social circle or in
your job where you're like,
this sounds like bullshit to me and you might be more apt to look a little
deeper and at the sides of it then you would have beforehand if you just get
used to the idea of a toe,
the line,
you know right here,
the official story nine 11 on forward are the official story.
Pearl Harbor.
I'm for it.
I hear the official story of how Jesus was born,
lived and died.
I'm for it.
And then you don't ever,
then you come up against something that doesn't fit and you're willing to step
back and look at it objectively and say,
this doesn't jive with my conscious.
Actually you have the skill built through critical thinking to look at.
And again,
you could,
you could do all the thinking about building seven.
You can do all the thinking about,
you know,
whether or not they wanted the TSA situation set up and all that kind of
bullshit,
um,
beforehand or the,
you know,
like the,
like the Conservatives groups had this,
you know,
build a Burg idea that they're going to craft human consciousness and put
lithium in the water and all that.
Alex Jones Shit.
You can believe that stuff.
You can explore it without going there and staying there.
And the same way that you can sort of arguably take DMT and not stay in that
brain stem position you can get trapped into the world was conspiracy.
You can get trapped.
Right.
And it's not
necessary.
The whole point is be aware,
be aware and don't just buy the straight line.
You know,
like one of my wiki leaks.
Yeah,
that's right.
I said,
you know,
I fucking conversation.
Go on forever.
House Pie.
No,
but it's over.
I know.
It's crazy.
Let's,
let's end it now.
Yeah.
Two hours and 40 minutes and we're just starting three hours.
I tunes crashes.
It does well,
bits out podcasts,
you stream you verbose cunts.
Yeah.
As you stream still on the air,
you stream,
you can't only,
it can only do three hours.
Yeah.
Record.
It can be blatant forever.
But we've done that a few times.
Yeah.
Props to house barks.
Thank you very much.
Surfing come in on the conversation.
Really.
Absolutely.
Awesome.
Good intelligent conversation with Mr. House barks.
You go out on Twitter.
How sparks,
that's his Twitter name and his website is,
is it helps parks.com.
How's parks.com and his band is zero.
The letter zero dash one.
And where's your band playing next?
Um,
where I think we're at the Brixton in February.
The Brixton was that her most of beach powerful Hermosa beach and then only
magic club in the house.
Love that place.
Right.
And then I think we're doing um,
like a shuttle with like Lacey whiskey or key club in February as well.
It's the whiskey.
There's lots of bitches were going to San Francisco,
tear and bad dads.
San Francisco.
Okay,
cool.
And they could find all this stuff on your website.
Yeah.
We'll,
we'll be posting dates and like the next month because we're booking them all
now.
Nice.
And Ladies and gentleman,
if you haven't seen the video that Brian made from Austin,
it is his piece did as his stalls.
It is his,
it's fucking brilliant.
It's the perfect length.
It leaves you wanting more.
I told him it should be longer,
but he's right because really it just leaves you just so,
so,
so good.
I watched it five times in a row,
man.
Fucking amazing.
I love watches.
Best editing ever and it's great and it's important.
You know that girl,
a Deb who was like,
I hate that song.
That Australian,
she lost her dog,
man.
Her dog disappear,
but she found it.
She found it.
Yeah.
So it was on Twitter.
Devo.
Awesome.
Everybody say congrats.
Devo Keefe right on Deb.
Oh k good on Ya.
He up that ground.
Fair.
Dinkum debow Keefe is a,
a radio DJ in Austin.
She's very cool.
And I was sad that she loves her dog and sad that she lost her dog for a bit.
But you've got to back.
It doesn't matter.
Bitches.
Props to the fleshlight.
Thank you very much for sponsoring our broadcast.
Um,
and again,
I get behind it.
It's a tool.
I have used it.
I use it on a regular basis.
It's awesome for shooting loads into it's way better than just masturbating.
You can go to Joe rogan.net and click the link and you get 15% off when you
enter in Rogan customer code.
I'm just here to help you beat off bitches.
I'm for it.
February 4th,
uh,
Mandalay Bay theater,
Joe Diaz,
Ari Shaffir and me.
Full death squad.
Perhaps Brian Red band will make an appearance.
Do you think you're up for going on stage and put of 2000 fucking people in
Vegas?
Okay.
Panic sets in.
I'm going to get him super,
super,
super high and then force them on stage and it's got too high last night.
I'm going on stage you high and get her under.
We'll have a boner on stage.
I don't want that dude.
Wait,
we're having the UFC podcast tomorrow.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Saturday,
Saturday.
Tell,
tell him what's the,
the uh,
how they find it.
Okay.
Just Twitter,
wet red band.
Twittered and so while the fights are going on,
listen,
this fucking package,
while the fights are going on,
red ban,
Sam,
Tripoli,
n Joey fucking Diaz,
you've gotta be doing commentary on the fight so you can watch alongside.
Joey's going to,
they're going to be smoking pot and just talking shit about the fights as it
goes down.
This shit is going to be epic.
I,
I would,
I really,
I'm going to,
I'm looking forward to that night after the fights are over,
going back to my hotel room and watching this before I get up in the morning.
I just made it a lot more people to it too.
It's just going to be a crazy amount of people.
A Ra.
She fears coming.
Danielle Stewart I think is coming.
Uh,
Taylor.
Vixen is coming.
Oh my God.
How do you have enough microphones for everybody?
I don't pass them around.
Yeah.
It's going to be more of a such a great idea.
When I quit working for the UFC,
that's what I'm going to do.
We're going to have a UFC parties and we're gonna.
We'll do it that way.
Yeah.
Flock.
That's going to be fun.
I can't wait to see that.
Anyway,
February 4th,
Mandalay Bay theater,
uh,
Joe Diaz,
Ari Shaffir and me tickets are going fast.
Um,
I'm very excited.
This is going to be a fucking killer show.
We used to do the house of Blues,
but we had a problem with them not wanting everybody to be seated.
And I need everybody to be seated.
That standing shit and comedy club at bars.
It's just too much of a pain in the ass for you too.
I don't want you to stand.
I went to one of my friends,
I went to Doug Stan hope show in La and it changed my mind on standing.
It's annoying,
man.
Yeah,
you get your feet hurt,
your back hurts.
Your fucking neck is cracking.
It's not an enjoyable show and it leads to people talking and it's not the right
environment.
So we decided to move to Mandalay Bay theater,
props to the House of Blues.
I still love you bitches,
but I've gotta move.
We've gotta move on this weekend.
UFC pay per view by it.
You whores.
And,
uh,
as usual,
I love all of you.
And,
uh,
we will see you next week.
Next week.
Did you get in touch with Eliza?
Uh,
no I haven't.
No.
Hopefully it will spawn.
So Twitter her,
and that's where your attack,
Eliza slessinger until her pitch on.
She doesn't even follow them.
I tried to send her a private message,
but she doesn't follow me.
Yeah.
We talked about flushing first level.
It's always sad when someone you liked us a folio.
Now
Valspar's falls me.
That's all.
It's important to use.
Dirty,
dirty bitches.
All right.
That's it.
The show's over at love.
You see you next week.
Bye.
Big cases.
And I'm on one on one and this one for you.
[inaudible].